ask yourself a simple question is the
world around you real it seems like the
answer should be pretty obvious of
course the world as you know it is real
how else would you be able to interact
with it perhaps a better question would
be this how much do you trust that the
world you know is real how much do you
believe that reality as you experience
it is constant and cannot be changed by
external
forces now imagine if you can an entity
to which the very fabric of reality is
like clay able to be shaped and molded
at will then imagine that this entity
this malicious twisted and unknowable
horror has taken a special interest in
you if you can picture such a scenario
then you may as well be standing in the
shoes of James tallaran a foundation
researcher assigned to SCP
3999 tallaran could only have imagine
what the foundation kept contained in an
airtight cell all the way at the bottom
of a kilometer long Sha
and never expected that this was where
his lifeless body would be found despite
having the entity contained the
foundation's only knowledge of SCP 3999
came from a text document discovered on
taran's phone after his demise even
their own records indicated that no such
creature ever existed why what could
possibly shape reality in such a way
that it could hide its own existence
from the
foundation and where was it now the
document on t phone yielded some
evidence seeming to be a long rambling
and Confused account of some sort of
battle between a reality shaping entity
and the ill- fated researchers sent to
examine it unlike many of the
foundation's documents the entry for SCP
3999 is riddled with contradictions and
strikethroughs a confusing mess of
information that makes piecing together
the mysteries of talin's Fate all the
more difficult beneath the strange
formatting and uncertainty surrounding
SCP 39 999 lies the tale of one man's
torture for the amusement of an
impossibly powerful and eternally
sadistic creature based on the
information available it appears that
SCP 3999 was fixated on tallaran upon
his arrival to the entity's cell the
researcher had no idea how long he would
spend in the company of SCP 3999 or that
he would never emerge alive many scps
contained by the foundation require
their own specially made prisons in
order to hold them and maintain the
safety of foundation staff as well as
the outside world but imagine if an SCP
could turn the tables bending the world
around a single member of the foundation
using all of reality as their own
personalized torture chamber the list of
Horrors endured by Taran is both
exhaustive and incomplete given the
length of time he spent with the
creature shortly after James tallaran
was assigned to site 118 where SCP 3999
was contained the The Entity was somehow
able to breach containment and began to
twist the world around it in the name of
a singular cruel objective the torture
of James
tallaran the creature while having no
physical description possessed the
capability to cause either a CK class
reality restructuring event or a ZK
Class end of reality event SCP 3999 was
somehow able to both destroy reality
itself while simultaneously rebuilding
it around its prisoner research
Taran Every Creature person and mination
that SCP 3999 created was done so with
the express intention of making tarant
suffer horribly over the course of
millions of years according to the
researchers own writings the exact
details of how SCP 3999 tortur Taran are
littered throughout the document he was
found with but it is apparent that the
entity was able to use its reality
altering abilities to continually revive
the man after killing him as a way to
prolong his pain SCP 3999 seemed to be
able to use its powers however it
pleased but focused all its attention
and actions on causing misery for one
man it simply enjoyed inflicting
suffering one of the examples of the
atrocities James Talan suffered at the
mercy of a cold remorseless creature was
witnessing the deaths of others although
they were constructed and controlled by
SCP
3999 tan saw Train Foundation security
Personnel drag three people into the
cell he recognized them instantly as his
own family Talan was made to watch as
his mother father and sister were
executed with a single gunshot to the
head by members of the same organization
that he was a part of all of taran's
professional colleagues were also killed
in front of him followed by anyone and
everyone that had come into contact with
James tallaran including the 05 Council
he was made to to watch as they were
systematically murdered one by one all
for the enjoyment of SCP
3999 at some point during the creatures
torture of tallaran there appears to
have been some attempt to contain SCP
3999 within another SCP SCP
2432 a room within a hotel now owned by
the foundation that appears to compel
its guests to write exaggerated positive
reviews after staying there when
introduced to SCP
2432 scp3 G9 99's ability to alter
reality seemed to have the effect of
creating a dimensional anomaly within
the hotel a crawl space opened up in SCP
2432 leading to an almost identical room
the front door of this new room
designated SCP
2432-22 the rooms of this new version of
the SCP 2432 Hotel were a seemingly INF
inite endless loop of rooms this
Dimension also played host to a number
of strange creatures as uncovered by
Foundation research teams that ventured
there most notably a creature resembling
a male Homo Sapien calling itself
researcher tallaran this being was
dressed in clothing similar to
Foundation researchers and appeared
nervous and confused when approached by
personnel only to be executed when as to
be told the location of SCP
3999 later during SCP 399 9's 3 milliony
year torture session James tallaran was
interviewed with another doctor working
for the
foundation the interviewing doctor had
no recollection of taran's assignment to
SCP
3999 and both James's involvement with
the foundation and the Very existence of
SCP 3999 work sponge from the
foundation's database as Taran
desperately tried to rationalize what
was happening to him he told the
interviewer I have trouble focusing on
things now I just feel feel a lot of
unease it's like reality has started to
feel less real if that makes sense
shortly after he attempted to ask the
doctor for his name and for him to
identify which of the foundation sites
they were at in response the doctor
emitted a strange noise from his mouth
confusing Taran that's not a name you
just made a noise with your mouth the
researcher replied why am I thinking of
redactions how can a word be redacted
like that in a normal conversation
following this the floor beneath James
taran's feet disappeared and he was
swallowed by Darkness as SCP 3999
continued bending reality to make him
suffer What followed were multiple
failed attempts from Taran to either
Escape From The Entity or nullify its
abilities to warp reality SCP 3999 had
at a later Point trapped Taran in a
stage playay version of itself as James
frantically tried to escape out of a
nearby door where he hoped to find
reality he was met with a solid wall I'm
trapped in whatever this place is with
this thing and there's no outside
reality anymore he realized researcher
Taran tried to understand the entity but
SCP 3999 defied description it was
simply chaos in his desperation tallarin
was able to dig a tiny hole in the floor
through which he could see a light
filled with thoughts of his beloved
family his colleagues and the rest of
the world that had once existed he
opened the hole wider it is unclear what
happened after this but it is a apparent
that James tallaran was still unable to
escape SCP
3999 however as the situations he found
himself in grew increasingly strange
James Taran was able to take greater
control of his predicament this is
evidenced in the foundation's document
regarding SCP
3999 researcher Taran cannot be
contained by this researcher tallaran
will fight his way back researcher Taran
will recontain SCP
this torture had gone on long enough and
researcher James tallaran was determined
to be free of the creature that had
taken such sick pleasure in his pain
Tarin at one point was able to subdue
SCP
3999 although it is initially unclear
how we accomplished this there were
several attempts made to contain the
entity using a recursive joke a melon
the graves of American Crime novelist
Robert B Parker or an 05 council member
in a roach motel It is believed that
every single one of these attempts
failed attempting to beat the creature
at its own game Tarin tried to turn SCP
3999 reality altering Powers against it
by imagining The Entity as something
easier to subdue these included several
moldy blankets a murderous penguin and a
pillow eventually Taran was able to
contain SCP 3999 with the aid of 48
trained containment Personnel all of
whom were also researcher Taran during
this time a conversation between the two
were partially recorded Ed although any
dialogue from SCP 3999 suffered from
data corruption claiming to finally be
in charge and in control of the
situation Taran interrogated SCP 3999
berading the creature for keeping him
prisoner you can't frighten me anymore
for the first million years of
nonsensical containment procedures and
tortures and dream logic it was the
worst pain I had ever felt but I
survived for the second million years it
was still the hardest thing I had ever
done but I survived by the third million
years I was growing numb the researcher
tried to ascertain the exact nature and
origin of SCP
3999 but to no avail vowing to fight The
Entity Torin told it here's the thing
about horror and weirdness the more you
reveal of it the less effect it has I am
sick of your horror I am sick of you
afterwards he was melted into goo for
five 5 years it appears that shortly
after this researcher teleran managed to
understand how to destroy SCP
3999 while the entity was Immortal and
virtually Unstoppable he realized its
weakness that it had to bond to another
being in order to survive upon
discovering this tallaran took his own
life causing all that SCP 3999 had done
to disappear after Foundation researcher
James Taran committed suicide reality
reverted to its original state before
SCP 3999 had heavily altered it his
death freeing reality from the evil
entity once and for all the foundation
remains unaware of what SCP 3999 was or
indeed is and one can only guess as to
why the entity subjugated tyerin to such
Terror and horror what made this
powerful reality Bender holds such a
perverse fixation on one man some have
likened the creature to a horror writer
Contin subjugating a character to all
manner of nightmares before deciding to
redraft and try something new whatever
it was SCP 3999 carries with it a
warning that reality isn't always as it
seems the fabric of our world is
littered with strange doorways if you
know where to look for them tears
portals
anomalies all leading to places and
plains Beyond human imagining and
understanding an SCP 2317 otherwise
known as a door to another world
certainly fits that description
contained and kept at all times under
the watch of arm guards SCP 2317 appears
to be a simple and unsuspecting wooden
door in its frame it hardly looks like
it requires such extreme round-the-clock
security or needs a strange secretive
ritual that the foundation performs
presumably to keep the door closed but
of course sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed doorway isn't where
it leavs needs it's what it keeps out
even by the foundation's already high
standards the requirements and
regulations for personnel who are
assigned to SCP 2317 seem oddly specific
psychological testing is standard
practice to work for the foundation but
an additional hurdle that anyone has to
clear before even getting to Glimpse at
this unassuming wooden door is having a
score of at least 72 on the MGR
obedience
examination it is also mandatory that
Personnel assigned to maintaining it are
both unmarried with no children or next
of Ken as well as an unwavering
unquestioning loyalty to the foundation
pure devotion to its code and
objectives these may seem like strange
requirements after all SCP 2317 is just
a door isn't
it perhaps there's a reason that the
foundation keeps so much of the
information about SCP 2317 buried deep
under layers upon layers of security
with only the overseer Council privy to
the full details of its strange nature
knowledge as they say is power but maybe
knowing too much about whatever is
behind that door can prove deadly still
if SCP 2317 is a door to another world
an alternate Dimension or parallel
reality it must be safe enough to visit
after all the foundation has been
sending Personnel in there on a regular
basis daily in fact according to the 5
Council this is done as part of a
procedure to maintain active containment
of something lurking beyond that old
wooden door frame but what could
possibly warrant such constant
maintenance and
surveillance in accordance with the
foundations guidelines all staff are
required to rotate out of observing SCP
2317 after every 2 months and spend the
following third month in full
psychological counseling before they are
permitted to return to the containment
unit housing the door to another world
it was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a foundation
guard was informed that his security
clearance has been raised to level three
and that he'd been selected for the duty
of carrying out 220 Calabasas he knew
the name instantly this was the title
given to the Daily containment procedure
that absolutely had to be carried out
the guard didn't question these orders
after all he'd been selected precisely
because of his loyalty to the
foundation he did make one EST to his
commanding officer however he wanted to
know what had happened to the last guard
that had performed the
procedure didn't make it out of
psychological evaluation the officer
replied not letting this affect his
dedication the guard was told to prepare
for procedure 220
Calabasas along with a fellow member of
foundation security Personnel the guard
was instructed to gather everything on a
strange list the first was a
pre-selected member of Class D Personnel
specifically convicted murderer class D
refers to disposable class Personnel
Expendable individuals recruited by the
foundation for the sole purpose of
testing
scps class D's were usually prison
inmates repurpose for SCP testing and
the one chosen for 220 Calabasas was no
exception serving multiple life
sentences for murders or at least that's
what the guard had been told a
foundation Personnel member instructed
him to refer to the class D solely as
the assistant from that point on
next the guard collected a live chicken
an obsidian edged knife a silver aspar
and aspersorium to be filled with 500
cc's of holy water that have been
blessed by a priest of the abrahamic
faith and finally a 1 kiloton nuclear
device which according to instructions
was only to be detonated in the unlikely
event of a catastrophic containment
failure in other words The Last
Resort after following his instructions
to the letter and without question the
guard and his colleague were briefed the
foundation Personnel member informed
them that he'd be joining in leading
them in the procedure the staff member
also specified that henceforth he'd be
referred to as the celebrant until the
completion of 220 Calabasas the guard
was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were but trusted in the
foundation knowing that if they wanted
this procedure performed a certain way
then it was an everyone's best interest
to carry out the orders to the letter
but what the celebrant then went on to
explain raised far more questions about
SCP
2317 and the nature of procedure 220
calabases the class D joining them
wasn't actually a Class D the assistant
as they were now referred to was in
reality another Foundation staff member
with a level four security clearance
specifically tailored to SCP
2317 every member of Staff entering
through SCP 2317 and taking an active
role in 22 Calabasas needed to be
informed that this assistant was not to
be harmed or treated as a member of
disposable class fighting back the
nagging question of why the foundation
would employ this
subterfuge the guard along with his
fellow security officer the celebrant
and assistant prepared for their
departure through the door to another
world at solar noon when the sun was
highest over SCP
2317 solar noon chickens and holy water
this all seemed like an oddly occult
combination for the
foundation as they entered the old
wooden door Beyond lay a Barren salt
plane stretching out for kilometers in
every direction this alternate Dimension
according to the briefing was designated
SCP 2317 Prime the guard immediately
noticed a ring of Seven Pillars directly
ahead of the group as they entered each
of them bearing intricately detailed
Engravings unlike anything from any era
of ancient history procedure 220
calabases was carried out quickly but
carefully the guard watching as the
celebrant and assistant were careful not
to miss a step first the celebrant
scattered holy water into the center of
the pillars with the aspergum and
aspersorium looking down at his feet and
keeping a steady Pace as he stepped
counterclockwise around them the guard
watched intently as the celebrant
completed his circuit around the pillars
and turned to the assistant anointing
his head with Holy Water Seven Seals
Seven Rings seven gr for the Scarlet
King he said aloud the assistant with
the obsidian blade in his hand took the
chicken and dispatched it in sacrifice
letting its blood mix with the holy
water he then repeated the celebrant
circuit in the opposite direction before
stepping into the center of the stone
pillars blood for the old gods water for
the new king the assistant recited
pouring the remaining mix of blood and
holy water over a patch of salt in the
middle of the Seven Pillars even though
he knew it wasn't his place to question
the foundation as the 220 calabases
procedure took place the guard couldn't
help but wonder what all this was for it
seems so ritualistic like something
deeply religious or even magical he
never bought into all that oul mumbo
jumbo even while working for the
foundation but he had learned not to
question anything even the strangest and
most inexplicable of
science little did he know that beneath
his feet was an ancient and unknowable
horror a beast Chained and lying in
weight contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars sat an impossibly
large creature humanoid and OB Beese its
body covered entirely in Scales thicker
than armor plating branch-like horns
protruded from its jawless head pointing
up to chains that hung from the Seven
Pillars above each one hooked into the
entity's back all but one of the the
chains was broken a final withering
shackle keeping the devour of worlds in
its underground prison ever since 1894
BCE when arikian Mystics imprisoned it
the devour has been waiting patiently
for its inevitable Freedom it knows as
well as the foundation that nothing can
be done to prevent the final chain from
one day breaking even procedure 220
Calabasas won't keep the creature
contained it's nothing more than a smoke
screen an act designed to create an
illusion of active containment and
maintain Foundation morale until a
permanent solution can be devised to
keep SCP
imprisoned of course if the guard had
known this it would have also explained
the need for a 1 kiloton nuclear device
as part of this stage ritual procedure
220 calabases had all the components to
trick everyone below the 05 Council
emulating religious and occult rituals
the increased level of security
surrounding the procedure and its
purpose and telling staff that any
failure to correctly and completely
perform the 220 calabases procedure will
result in an XK Class end of the world
scenario all these elements work
together to conceal the truth that one
day the Devourer will escape and lay
waste to our
Dimension knowledge is power and maybe
knowing too much truly is deadly
perhaps if the guard had learned any of
this he'd have understood why his
predecessor never made it out of
psychological
evaluation maybe if he had questioned
the purpose of procedure 220 calabases
he'd have learned the true nature of SCP
2317 and what that doorway kept out but
he was loyal to the foundation through
and through as the team finished
performing 220 Calabasas and returned
through the wooden door the guard took
one last glance over his shoulder at the
vast salt plane the entire Dimension was
calm silent but not peaceful it was
patient The Entity had waited centuries
for its time and now all it would take
was the breaking of this seventh and
final chain one day the door was closed
behind the guard as he the celebrant the
assistant and his fellow security
officers Ste back through their work
done and as far as they knew preventing
catastrophe for another day only the
foundation hups the overseer Council are
aware of the true danger posed by SCP
2317 and its sole
inhabitant current predictions are that
at some point within the next 30 Years
the Devourer of Worlds will be freed any
and all attempts to repair or recreate
the chains holding it in place have so
far failed as such the 05 Council has
elected to continue providing Foundation
personnel with the ignorant hope that
procedure 220 calabasis is an effective
strategy for containment as we've said
sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed door isn't where it leads
it's what it keeps out in the case of
sccp 2317 the unassuming wooden door
holds at Bay an ancient creature of
Untold power that will one day break
free and wreck havoc in our
Dimension nothing the foundation does
can prevent it or keep it contained
behind the door to another world and
only the overseer Council knows that any
and all efforts to do so are
futile with all that in mind we can only
hope that the doorway of SCP 2317 stays
closed at least for a little while
longer it isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic furniture
inide inside the world's scariest living
room but it's also insanely complicated
how do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities rather than a single object
location or being SCP 001 is a cluster
of over 30 different proposals for
potential candidates for the prestigious
001 spot some believe there's a true 001
hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys others think that these are all
just as CPS cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the SCP 001 Throne we're not
here to make a final judgment instead
we're going to take you on a lightning
round crash course through 31 of the SCP
001 proposals if you'd like a more
in-depth take on any of these scps let
us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chief of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the sheath of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this Account Details the
capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr keer was killed
inspiring the creation of the infamous
keer class in his honor number 29 the
gate Guardian this huge multi-wing sword
wielding biblical energy being may have
been the impetus for the founding of the
SCP Foundation this being remains
largely static guarding the intersection
of the ous and Euphrates rivers its
flaming sword which is believed to be as
hot as the sun can cleave any aggressor
out of existence at the atomic level
when the founder of the SCP Foundation
First encountered the gate Guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind prepare and the rest is history
number 28 the lock this onx gemstone and
the incredibly complex lock attached to
it are still a mystery to this day all
attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshipper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled counter
coun clockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
transdimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 25 four the database in one of
the strangest twists on the format this
SCP is actually the various authors of
the SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 36 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keer duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keer class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four sub
proposals remember what we said about
complicated these sub proposals include
the children nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive
potential in together the broken God aka
mechan the god of metal intelligence and
machines atonement a researcher turned
into a humanoid Singularity with the
power to destroy whole reality
and the way it ends which isn't
technically an SCP but the tales of the
chaos Insurgency quest to eliminate all
the members of the foundation's 05
Council number 19 a record this is an
SCP file slot that is itself an SCP
whatever is written into the slot
becomes true and one ambitious
researcher attempted to use this power
to make herself into a kind of all
powerful God number 18 past and future
these scps are a collection of powerful
entities that despise Humanity and are
apparently the source of all anomalous
phenomena even making already dangerous
scps deadlier than before much like the
database those pesky SCP Wiki writers
might have something to do with this
number 17 the consensus this SCP refers
to a reality restructuring event caused
by an occult war in a previous reality
that's right this SCP already won and
we're living in its new reality the only
people who remember the world as it once
was are 13 people who now form the 05
Council and not all of them are telling
the truth about what they know number 16
when day breaks this proposal details a
potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon
wherein the sun becomes hostile and
begins to melt all living beings into a
living wax-like substance number 15
God's blind spot this is an anomalous
area referred to as facility T in which
nobody can die this anomaly dates back
to the biblical ages of Moses and is
believed to have originated from the
literal blessing of the abrahamic god
it's through a Covenant with this God
that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death free area
number 14 normaly ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the 05
Council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another Dimensions SCP Foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12 dead men this SCP was an
84-year-old man whose body when damaged
and mutilated can affect the very
processes of human Death At Large before
his own death he was used as a dangerous
Pawn in a civil war between 05 command
and the SCP Foundation Ethics Committee
yeah we were surprised to hear they had
an Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10 the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extradimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
SCP 231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of scp-231-7
you better hope you're already dead by
then number nine a simple toy maker AKA
Dr Wonder tainment this is a reality
vendor who appears to be a normal human
male but has the ability to create other
anomalous objects a number of which are
now cataloged as CPS number eight story
of your life this is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained within conforms to a narrative
structure number seven a good boy this
is another anomalous entity created
accidentally by the foundation itself a
neural network was fed information on
other anomalous entities in order to
help the foundation come up with better
containment and neutralization
procedures problem was the computer got
way way too eager with the
neutralization part number six project
Palisade this is another anomaly created
by the foundation this time to combat a
potentially reality destroying entity
known as the worm the foundation created
a number of alternate realities as
Shields but it's possible that this just
made the worm stronger number five
05-13 the final member of the 05 Council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the 05 Council are anomalous 051 13's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number four
fish hook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
SCP 001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
injury number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in in the foundation's control the
solution is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world SCP
Containment Breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality with
incomplete data this is the world we
exist in now with no knowledge of what
came before and how it differed from the
world we experience today okay finally
number one the tendal Trinity put very
simply the tendal Trinity represents
three timelines that converge and feed
back in on themselves even trying to
summarize this one is near impossible as
its strangeness and complexity resists
all reduction you can hunt down the
tendal Lo Trinity yourself and hope to
unpack its Secrets but don't say we
didn't warn you so that's SCP 001 is it
one of them all of them or even none of
them perhaps that's a question best left
up to the foundation or maybe the simple
answer answer is that you're just not
meant to know we're talking about
information so privileged here that it's
protected by a mimic kill agent that'll
quite literally make you drop dead if
you view the files without proper
authorization you do have proper
authorization right it all started in
1983 with reports of human trafficking
in the heart of Sin City the FBI had
gotten word of a potential trafficking
ring operating out of an abandoned
department store in Las Vegas Nevada and
immediately began organizing a secret
raid on the building while they would
indeed encounter something horrifying
within that abandoned department store
it wasn't criminals or human trafficking
in fact it wasn't human at all this is
the horrifying story of SCP 847 after
weeks of planning the raid on the
department store was conducted in the
dead of night agents covered all the
exits and entrances and a helicopter was
stationed nearby in case anyone
attempted to run it should have been a
perfect trap but things never go as
planned when you don't know what you're
dealing with the agents breached the
door and began searching the darkened
building it didn't appear that there was
any power so the traffickers must have
had great night vision and a high
tolerance for creepy locals agents soon
heard a faint humming sound coming from
below a generator it must be located in
the basement and be the Hub of this
criminal Enterprise readying themselves
for whatever they were about to find the
agents descended into the basement as
they moved deeper into the building they
found that lighting rigs had been set up
they must be getting closer to something
but that something was still a mystery a
senior FBI special agent was leading the
charge his pistol drawn and ready it was
quiet too quiet did the traffickers
already realize they were coming and
clear out he was ready to consider this
bust to bust when he heard a quiet muing
in the distance a persistant whining
whimper that was
undeniably human he gave the signal to
his fellow agents to follow the noise
they proceeded forward towards the pain
sounds and found themselves in a wide
well-lit room filled with department
store mannequins all were broken to some
degree some were totally smashed to
Pieces some were chained to walls and
locked in cages others were wrapped in
plastic the agent wondered whether this
was some kind of Twisted joke or a
messed up avanguard art piece that's
when he noticed her a single Crouch
figure in the distance hunched over and
whimpering in a darkened corner of the
room near a fulllength mirror he
couldn't fully make her out but he got
the sense that something was wrong she
was injured bent over was she even
missing an arm just what have these
monsters done to this woman he whispered
a request for back up into His Radio and
pushed on when he got within 50 m of
this strange woman her demeanor changed
entirely she jerked around her movements
forced erratic and painful looking the
woman stared directly into the agent
eyes and began hobbling towards him
occasionally stopping to strike a pose
as if modeling during a photo shoot just
then the agent made a horrifying
realization this thing moving towards
them wasn't a woman at all it was a
living mannequin as she got closer
though he realized that the mannequin's
broken left forearm had been carved into
a large shiv a female Junior FBI agent
had been one of the many to pour into
the room when the raid leader had
radioed for backup the second she
entered the met range of this strange
mannequin everything changed in an
instant its eyes and mouth began
dripping with a thick viscous resin its
whimpering gasps suddenly became vicious
earsplitting screeches and it turned its
gaze from the senior FBI agent it was
now focused on the junior agent who had
just entered the room and broke into a
terrifying run straight towards her the
mannequin moved with a violent
single-minded purpose other agents began
firing but it was running fre freakishly
fast and easily dodged most of the
bullets the few that actually hit seemed
to do nothing to slow the creature down
it Shrugged off the damage and kept
running with a great leap it landed on
the terrified Junior agent and began
jabbing her with its bladed arm the
other agents stopped firing fearing they
might accidentally hit their colleague
during the Panic the mannequin was
ruthless clawing and stabbing with the
strange resin leaking out of its every
orifice terrified and unable to reach
her gun the agent remembered her
training she reached into her belt and
grabbed her stun gun jamming the two
probes up against the creature's chest
and giving at 30,000 volts the creature
spasmed fell backwards and collapsed in
a heap on the ground Frozen this was the
first recorded encounter with SCP 847 a
violent living mannequin with a serious
problem with women this terrifying
report was passed up the chain of
command until it landed on the desk of a
foundation agent working in in the FBI
the foundation quickly swooped in and
claimed the mannequin delivered
necessary amnestic treatment to all who'
witnessed it and closely observe the
female Junior FBI agent's recovery in a
private hospital with Foundation ties as
it turns out they were right to do so as
the junior agent was in for a gruesome
fate while the wound she'd suffered at
the hands of SCP 847 didn't appear fatal
the fact that the mannequin's anomalous
resin excretions entered the open wound
changed everything
several hours after being committed the
junior agent began complaining of limb
stiffness and difficulty moving this
quickly developed into full paralysis
over time her skin and internal organs
began to harden until the process dub
plastination came to a gruesome end the
junior agent wasn't just dead she had
been transformed into a mannequin
Foundation researchers were met with a
truly horrifying realization this means
that all the other Broken Mannequins
found found with SCP 8847 were likely
once living humans attacked and
transformed by the anomaly now a source
for new harvested body parts now safely
interred at a foundation containment
facility though the real tests on SCP
847 to determine its behavior and
physical attributes could begin the most
important detail about SCP 847 is that
its aggression is exclusively directed
towards women as opposed to when it
encounters men and its instincts are
more self-destructive through a series
of tests and observations researchers
have been able to Pinn down three
different distinct patterns of behavior
for SCP 847 pattern Z behaviors occur
when there are no humans standing within
50 m of SCP 847 the mannequin will seek
out a ful length mirror and pose in
front of it much like a department store
mannequin attempting to show off its
clothes it remains largely inanimate
during the periods and will very
occasionally use a finger or whatever
appendage is available given its habit
for self-mutilation to scratch messages
on nearby surfaces pattern y Behavior
occurs when male humans with XY
chromosomes enter a 50 m radius around
SCP 847 just like its reaction to the
male FBI agents who found it 847 will
initially emit vocalizations that seem
like whimpering gasps before making eye
contact and striking provoc poses while
approaching the subject it will then
remain static and allow the male subject
to pose its body however after the male
subject leaves the area 847 will enter a
state of considerable distress and begin
removing or shattering parts of its body
the foundation has found that the parts
removed or shattered are often
consistent with parts that the male
subjects found displeasing during
interactions showing a masochistic
desire to impress these parts are then
harvested back from plastinated Vic VI
which brings us to the most dangerous of
Its Behavior patterns pattern X
behaviors occur when female humans enter
a 50m radius around the creature 847
will immediately become brutally
aggressive switching its noises from
whimpers to violent screeches and growls
847 experiences enhanced physical
capabilities during pattern X states its
speed has been measured at 45 kmph
making it as fast as the legendary SCP
09 6 it's also been shown to exhibit
extreme physical strength it's during
this pattern of behavior that it begins
excreting its deadly resin which has
been proven to only be dangerous to
women in these states the only thing
capable of reliably pacifying the being
is a powerful electric shock the shock
causes the creature's resin to harden
temporarily incapacitating it for
roughly 5 minutes other Conventional
Weapons and damage has no meaningful
effect on SCP
847 after a number of incidents that had
sad and violent endings the foundation
Ethics Committee forbade the use of
female d-class Personnel in SCP 847
testing when it came to female subjects
847 always slipped into a state of
extreme aggression so instead the
foundation began testing with male
subjects in hopes of better
understanding the Dynamics between human
males and SCP 847 various misogynistic
d-class males were introduced into the
containment chamber which was modeled to
look like a bedroom for the purposes of
Behavioral study each one either during
or after their interaction with SCP 847
was told to comment on some aspect they
felt dissatisfied with the mannequin
shattered its own chest after hearing it
described as being out of proportion
after another d-class called its nose
ugly the mannequin broke it off after
another said that its hair was out of
fashion and commented on its inability
to drink it tore out its hair hair and
liver all parts were replaced after the
experiments things took their most
violent and upsetting turn yet with the
introduction of
d729 a lot of the time d-class Personnel
are considered to be as Anonymous as
they are expendable but d729 4 is an
exception before becoming d-class he was
a successful cello teacher who brutally
murdered one of his teenage students and
her mother he's typically employed in
tests when the foundation wishes to see
intera between anomalies and humans with
confirmed Psychopathic personalities
during his interaction with SCP 847 he
belittled and humiliated the mannequin
he forced it into uncomfortable poses
and even snapped off one of its fingers
before being dragged from the room by
Foundation guards in the following
debrief he further bered the mannequin
as useless and lousy at its job of being
controlled by him in response 847
extracted its own brains eyes and and
clavicle before shattering its own hands
in dismay so why does 847 behave this
way while it may appear monstrous it
seems that the reason SCP 847 does what
it does is All Too Human it hurts women
because it itself is hurting and it's
willing to hurt itself even more for the
approval of the objects of its desire as
a result it's an anomaly trapped in an
endless cycle of pain and violence
perhaps one day it'll be able to free
itself from the loop but that day is
unlikely to come for this murderous
mannequin anytime soon stop me if you've
heard this one before a young man was
driving home from work late one rainy
night when he spotted a woman in a white
dress and a red sweater walking along
the shoulder of the road concerned for
her safety he slowed down and rolled
down the window so he could talk to her
when he asked where she was going she
said she was walking to her parents'
house the man pulled over and offered
her a ride that she accepted the woman
gave him the address of her home hopped
in the back seat and the man drove off
he sensed that she must have been cold
from walking in the rain so he cranked
up the car's heater to help her dry off
soon she removed her heavy red sweater
and placed it on the seat next to her
the man tried to make friendly
conversation asking if the woman had a
job what she was studying at school
where'd she been that day but she
remained quiet staring out the window
until they drove past an old graveyard
the woman began pounding on the glass of
the car as if she desperately wanted
something unsure of what to do the man
pulled over but before he could ask her
what was happening she had gotten out of
the car he exited the car to try and
find her but the woman was nowhere to be
seen she must have somehow ran off
confused the man got back in his car and
drove away he went on his way and didn't
think of it again until the next day
when he noticed her sweater was still in
the back of his car he decided to go to
the house house she had originally given
him the address for and give it back to
her he found the home without any
trouble but when he knocked on the door
the old woman who answered it was
confused by his story she told him that
her daughter couldn't have possibly left
her sweater in his car because she died
in a car accident 30 years ago the
vanishing hitchhiker is a classic ghost
story with the details varying from
place to place and Storyteller to
Storyteller in Chicago she goes by
Resurrection Mary named after the Great
graveyard she asks for rides to in
okanawa Japan she's known as the night
walker of Nago and she only appears to
taxi drivers in Kent England she's
Suzanne a bride killed in a car wreck on
the way to her bachelorette party in
North Carolina her name is Lydia and in
Hawaii she's believed to be the goddess
Pelle in human form but as far as our
friends at the SCP Foundation are
concerned the vanishing hitchhiker's
name is Mary talish also known as SCP
1337 on the 19th of May 1952 College
sophomore Mary talish was abducted on
her way to class in her hometown of Muny
Indiana when police found her body 2
weeks later her eyes and heart had been
torn from her body in a ritualistic
fashion and she had scrapes and bruises
that suggested she had been beaten
before her murder her killers were never
caught and her body was returned to her
family for burial in tment in Cemetery
starting on the 19th of June that same
year someone matching Mary's description
a Caucasian woman with blonde hair
standing 150 cm tall and wearing a red
sweater was spotted trying to fly down
passing Vehicles along Mayflower Road
since then every month on the 19th Mary
has been cited along that stretch of
road and every month the same scenario
plays out Mary gives anyone who picks
her up directions to her parents' house
then on the way she instructs the driver
to stop at the graveyard where she was
buried she vanishes from the car leaving
her sweater the driver of the car tries
to return the sweater to her parents
house only to be told that Mary talish
was dead when the SCP Foundation was
made aware of Mary tales's pattern of
Haunting in the late 50s they set up a
system where agents would Patrol
Mayflower Road at hourly intervals with
the intention of picking Mary up agents
were sent on their own in non-foundation
cars and instructed to stick to the
accepted script of the vanishing
hitchhiker Legend without attempting to
engage Mary in further conversation
Mary's parents were also given E-class
agent status to keep them from speaking
about the haunting and told that the
foundation was working on a way to set
the spirit to rest early attempts to
study The Apparition were inconclusive
it proved impossible for the foundation
to relocate her or trigger her
manifestation outside of the 19th of
every month in attempts to analyze her
sweater were fruitless since if the
sweater wasn't returned to the talish
family home it would simply vanish from
containment at or around sunset on the
next 19th for 20 years SCP 1337 events
continue to happen as normal d-class
Personnel under the instruction of the
foundation would pick Mary up drive her
past the cemetery and return her sweater
to her parents it was business as usual
and in fact it was one of the more
sedate reoccurring apparitions the
foundation had to deal with but as you
might have guessed that piece wouldn't
last forever and Dr Lawson who in 1972
was placed in charge of all resources
regarding SCP
1337 Dr Lawson was getting sick of all
this Phantom hitchhiker business and
while most of the foundation was happy
to keep this routine going Lawson
thought that the continual picking up
and dropping off of Mary talish and her
red sweater was a waste of the
foundation's valuable time after all it
was the early '70s the price of oil was
at an all-time high so the expense of
sending car after car up and down the
same road for a solid day once a month
just to pick up a ghost was more trouble
than it was worth so Lawson started
developing a plan one that he didn't go
through the proper Foundation channels
to approve he reasoned that the reason
Mary's ghost kept coming back was
because she wanted something since
always asked for a ride home then it
must mean she wanted to return back to
her parents so logic followed that if
she had nothing or no one to go back to
then she'd stop appearing on the 18th of
June 1973 Lawson went ahead with his
plan without his superior's knowledge
and ordered the execution of Mary
tales's parents as well as the immediate
demolition of their family home
according to his journals Lawson had
hoped that his attempt at
decommissioning 1337 would significantly
cut the foundation's gas bills freeing
up valuable funds at which point he'd
surely be promoted in recognition of his
Brilliance but that wasn't what happened
lost was demoted from team leader to
junior staff and only kept on 1337
detail out of the belief that without a
family to return to Lawson would become
the new focal point of The Haunting
should Mary talish ever return though
Lawson's actions weren't at all above
board even by a SCP Foundation standards
they did seem to have worked the 19th of
June came and went without a single Mary
sighting and she wasn't seen the next
month either a full year went by without
any sign of the Mayflower Road
apparition Miss satisfied with this turn
of events the foundation made the
decision to officially reclassify SCP
1337 from safe to Safe decommissioned
and the gas money that was budgeted for
the Mayflower Road Patrol was redirected
to the SCP 682 tank acid fund but even
though everything seemed to have been
sorted out Lawson wasn't entirely
satisfied and not just because of his
demotion whether it was Intuition or
merely guilt induced paranoia is unclear
but he suspected that Mary was still out
there somewhere at first he thought that
she might show up on the anniversary of
her parents' deaths but then that date
came and went as did eight more
anniversaries after it finally on the
19th of June 1983 Lawson decided he had
to see for himself fitted with recording
equipment he drove alone in a
non-foundation standard car down that
lonely stretch of road where so many
before him had stopped to pick up that
mysterious blonde woman with the red
sweater he had to prove to himself that
she wouldn't show up that he had really
and truly gotten rid of her for good it
was about 5:00 in the evening when he
reached Mayflower Road at first he
didn't experience anything strange he
scanned the roadside looking for the
Phantom hitchhiker walking along it but
there was nobody there Dr Lawson
breathed a sigh of relief he may have
orchestrated the deaths of two innocent
people but at least it hadn't been for
nothing he turned on the recorder he
brought with him and log that nothing
had happened SCP 1337 had been
permanently neutralized as he approached
the T intersection and prepared to turn
onto Marsh Avenue he looked up to adjust
his rearview mirror to his horror he
found that he wasn't alone in the car
someone was in the seat behind him
someone with blonde hair and a red
sweater his last transmission consisted
only of wait who the hell are you before
the recording abruptly stopped Lawson's
car was found soon after by Foundation
agents Lawson was dead in the front seat
bruised and bloody with his eyes and
heart ripped out in a ritualistic
fashion just the way Mary talish had
been found all the way back in
1952 it turns out that Mary hadn't been
neutralized after all she'd just been
waiting for a chance to get revenge on
the man who killed her family and Mary
didn't stop with Dr Lawson no longer
does she appear walking along the road
waiting for someone to offer her a ride
before disappearing without incident now
should someone pass by without offering
a ride she will appear in their back
seat before reenacting the method of her
own death upon the driver and her
physical appearance has changed too
whereas before she looked like the image
of a pretty young woman before her
tragedy now recording show that she
appears with the wounds of her death
present her eyes gouged out in their
sockets and a massive hole in her chest
where her heart should be the same
wounds she inflicts on her victims the
SCP Foundation has tried closing off and
eventually destroying the road but that
has only resulted in Mary manifesting at
other locations in and around Muny
Foundation documents reveal that any
Back Road in the city can potentially
serve as host to a 1337 event and all
attempts to contain The Apparition have
failed the only way someone who has seen
Mary can avoid her wrath is by stopping
to pick her up at which point she will
dematerialize before reappearing on
another road mobile task forces have
been unsuccessful as Mary only appears
to those driving alone and all agents
who have been sent on solo missions to
apprehend her have resulted in the death
of the agent as SCP 1337 was reinstated
this time as uclid class currently the
foundation's method of managing SCP 1337
is to dispatch a security team on the
19th of every month to monitor all the
places where a potential sighting could
take place as soon as signs of a
manifestation are identified a remotely
controlled vehicle containing a single
DCL class is driven to the location once
Mary appears in the car the car is
piloted to the empty lot where her home
used to stand and the remains of the
d-class are then disposed of like a lot
of the stories that could pass down as
urban legends the story of SCP 1337 has
a lesson that can be taken away from it
this SCP started off as an ordinary
local haunting no more deadly than Lydia
Suzanne Resurrection Mary or any of the
countless other local versions of the
vanishing hitchhiker story but thanks to
one Rogue Foundation doctor and his
desire to rush what he thought would be
an efficient solution the spirit not
only became harder to control but also
much more violent and bloodthirsty than
anyone was prepared to deal with so if
there's anything we can learn here it's
that no matter if you're a student an
office worker or a researcher with the
SCP Foundation think twice about cutting
Corners it might save you a little bit
of time and money in the short term but
in the long term the results could be
fatal it was the summer of 2012 in
Damascus and for the people of Syria it
certainly seemed like all the
predictions about the end of the world
were coming true the Syrian Civil War
was raging between multiple Rebel groups
and the dictator Bashar Assad whose
government was shelling its own people
as well as using chemical weapons and
brutal campaigns of violence across the
country in hopes of quelling the
Rebellion little did they know amidst
all this pain and bloodshed something
even more dangerous was brewing an
anomalous phenomenon in the sunny Plains
north of Damascus that may pose a threat
to all of humanity someday a threat
known to the SCP Foundation as SCP
3989 the bone Orchard this temporal and
spatial anomaly was discovered a few
years earlier in 2009 before the Syrian
Civil War even officially began it's
strange for a highly dangerous ker class
anomaly to be discovered under such
seemingly mundane circumstances the SCP
Foundation first became aware of SCP
3989 after a small Olive Orchard owner
sold a strangely high amount of Olives
that shouldn't have been possible when
compared to his reported number of OA
europea olive trees field agents were
dispatched to question the owner about
his sudden success success but he was
resistant to questioning the agents
began a covert surveillance operation to
figure out what was actually going on
here at which point they discovered a
considerable spatial anomaly the olive
Orchard was Far bigger on the inside the
property was seized by the foundation
for containment the owner had no real
knowledge of the spatial anomaly it's
likely he just decided not to look a
gift horse in the mouth while making
money hand over fist from the extra
olives he sold the owner was given am N
Sticks and a new line life as the
foundation began to study this anomaly
which was now labeled SCP
3989 to this day no researcher has been
able to figure out the origin of 3989
anomalous qualities it was first given a
uclid class designation and cordon off
from the public with a simple chain link
fence while Foundation investigations
were underway on the inside on a map the
plot of land the olive Farm should
occupy is about 5 square acres but this
plot contains an un seen portal to a
pocket Dimension within its 12 M active
Zone which doesn't follow the same
spatial laws that our reality does this
subdimension known as SCP
3989 is a hot bed of fascinating
anomalous activity upon discovery of
this Hot Zone the foundation established
the nearby area 126 as a research center
and a makeshift containment facility for
any anomalous entities captured from SCP
3989 daa it seemed like the Foundation
really had a handle on this situation
but they were blissfully unaware of the
true Horrors lurking with an SCP 3989 d
a but they'd soon find out in the most
horrifying way possible Dr far gazelli
was assigned to head the research into
the anomalous Zone within 3989 and
naturally he began organizing fact-f
finding Expeditions Into the Heart of
the affected area the first skinny pig
to head into The Hot Zone was former
Foundation agent hosiah Herrick who'd
been demoted to the lowly d-class
position of D1
12615 due to failures on a previous
Mission with a remote link to Dr gazelli
heric was forced to venture into the
active anomalous Zone to collect footage
and samples of the Flora and Fauna
within the first thing herck noticed on
his expedition was the strange quality
of the olive trees within the active
Zone The Bark was a stark white and the
leaves of bloody red up close her could
see that the Trunks and branches of the
trees had undergone a process known as
oifc where the material slowly becomes
bone or bone-like tissue hence the
anomaly's creepy name the bone Orchard
these aifi trees became known as SCP
39891 heric also made another Discovery
all over the trees and ground were
wormlike creatures that looked like long
maggots that the foundation dubbed SCP
3989 d1a agent herck then noticed
something was off about the leaves of
the oide trees they were beating he
looked closer and they appeared to be
heart tissue filled with pumping veins
Dr gazelli ordered herck to take a
branch for testing and when he did the
tree began to bleed when he looked down
he saw that the wormlike creatures that
covered the ground were now crawling up
his legs ignoring orders from Dr gazelli
herck fled from the active Zone in
Terror as he left Dr gazelli caught
something in the corner of herrick's
body cam footage a long white hind limb
disappearing behind a tree back in our
normal Dimension tests on the sample
Hera collected yielded more upsetting
discoveries genetically the trees were
identical to humans the trunks were
human bone and the leaves really were
made of human heart tissue fascinated
and just a little bit horrified Dr
gazelli authorized further Expeditions
into
3989 this time though aan herck would be
accompanied by another d-class and both
would be armed with handguns and
protective body arms armor as it would
turn out this Expedition would be even
more horrifying than the first as the
two DCL classes explored the active
zones to collect further samples they
found that the worms were responsible
for the
osificante Ed to remove the fruit it
burst releasing more worm creatures it
seemed that the converted trees acted as
incubators for their egg sacks before
the duo could return with the samples
they were able to take the creature that
had been spotted on herrick's body cam
during the first mission finally
appeared it was huge with long white
Limbs and no facial features except for
a huge mouth it grabbed herrick's
companion and literally ate the top half
of his body in a single bite before
dropping his legs to the ground this
horrifying Beast and the many others
like it would later be designated as SCP
3989 d2a herck pulled out his sidearm
and shot the creature several times the
creature ignored the bullets though and
charged herck the feed from his body cam
cut out soon after both men were
declared killed in action and in
recognition of his sacrifice Josiah
herck was posthumously reinstated to his
old position in the foundation job well
done agent Dr gazelli meanwhile prepared
for the next mission this time knowing
of the clear dangers present within the
bone Orchard Dr gazelli recruited the
help of MTF Zeta 9 aka the mle rats
three members referred to as Charlie
team were sent into the anomalous Zone
once again remotely directed by Dr
gazelli they were equipped with
experimental ultrasound technology so
they could scan the fruit of the trees
within 3989 daa without breaking any and
incurring the wrath of 3989 d2a which
seem to act as centuries for the trees
early on in their Journey they found the
body of agent heric crucified against
one of the aifi trees his skin covered
in mysterious symbols that were likely
of saric origin while we don't have time
to fully explore sarcasm that will
require a video explanation all of its
own all you need to know is that it's a
dangerous religious cult that worships
flesh and disease and has close ties to
similar dangerous anomalies
like SCP 610 also known as the flesh
that hates people familiar with that SCP
will note eerily strange similarities to
some of the things the mole rats were
about to encounter as Charlie team
explored they saw a huge number of 3989
2A observing them with eyeless faces
from between the aifi trees they pressed
on until they discovered what seemed to
be an entirely new kind of tree within
the bone Orchard SCP 3989 -2 were huge
trees made out of what appears to be
enlarged human spines in place of a
trunk the smaller Twigs on the tree were
made from heart and lung tissue and the
whole thing was covered in what appeared
to be human amniotic Sachs Charlie team
attempted to use their ultrasound
scanners to discover the contents of
these sacks but one of them exploded in
the process releasing an entirely new
variety of monster from the Sachs
emerged the larvel stage of SCP 3989 -2b
smaller humanoid monsters with no faces
No sensory organs two pelvises four legs
and an exposed spine suddenly Charlie
team could feel a horrifying saric
presence around them which one member of
the team described as being like someone
grabbing her liver and giggling in her
face as the various Monsters of the bone
Orchard began to converge on the team
the voice of the saric prophet of War
and the hunt Oro began sounding in their
ears he was beckoning them to join him
while Charlie team fled from the active
Zone Dr gazelli felt increasingly drawn
into it he heard the voice of Oro and he
liked what he heard little by little the
workers of area 126 were losing their
minds manipulated by the saric power of
the bone orchard right next to them day
after day they were no longer loyal to
the foundation they wanted to serve
their new Dark Masters the fourth and
final expedition was led by Dr gazelli
himself he took a band of loyal
followers and one non-believer on a
quest into the active Zone to find an
orchan Temple they believed was hidden
in the very heart of the bone Orchard
once they were inside gazeli and his
loyalists murdered the non-believer as a
sacrifice to their new master They
carried on until they eventually found
what they were looking for a giant Stone
Temple resembling an Aztec zigurat
dubbed SCP 3989 -4 there they also
encountered a new kind of monster dubbed
SCP
39893 these beasts were larger than the
others and resembled ancient warriors
they had insect-like exoskeletal armor
horned heads additional Hind and
forelimbs and integrated bladed weapons
what Dr gazelli and his companions
thought would be paradise turned out to
be a kind of hell as they were led into
the temple where temporal and spatial
distortions broke their
and the multiple highly aggressive
instances of SCP
39893 -2a and -2b broke their bodies the
whole thing had been a horrifying trap
in that moment back at area 126 another
fleshy horrifying tree sprouted out of
the ground in the middle of the complex
monsters that had once been Dr gazelli
and his followers emerged from its
amniotic sacks and all hell broke loose
throughout the complex
soon enough the base was crawling with
monsters from the bone Orchard and staff
who become brainwashed ciric cultists
working in service of Oro humans were
gathered up to be sacrificed to the ever
growing number of anomalous trees things
came to a head when the anomaly in area
126 was visited by an outside agent from
the foundation working on behalf of the
Hazardous Materials containment liaison
biological containment specialist Dr
Marshall Grant and his team arrived at
the site and were horri if IED to see
the saric nightmare that had unfolded
they quickly engaged in a firefight with
the anomalous creatures and saric
devotees who'd gained control over area
126 a number of Dr Grant's team were
lost in the process but thankfully they
were able to eventually regain control
of the base and the anomalous area after
this incident SCP 3989 was upgraded to
ker class and given a huge upgrade in
security including 4 M High concrete
walls and a platoon siiz Regiment of
mobile task force members with heavy
Weaponry the force that took over the
minds of those exposed was designated
SCP
39895 a force so powerful that those
infected are given the choice to
self-terminate or be contained forever
this may seem like a somewhat happy
ending to a grim Tale But one detail
keeps Dr Grant and everyone at the
foundation who is forced to deal with
3989 awake at night according to all
recent studies into the bone Orchard it
isn't contained at all in fact the
active zone is getting bigger there was
destruction there was seemingly endless
death humanity went from the top of the
food chain to scarcely a blip on the
face of the Earth as the weasels
conquered Every Nation every scrap of
land and then came her hello there
friend have you heard the good news
about pallet the immaculate she is the
one who liberates ated the human race
from death and suffering who saved us
from the invasion of the cruel invading
alien weasels she brought Humanity back
from the brink of Extinction and blessed
us all with immortality and eternal
youth she also draws some very nice
pictures but that's more of a hobby than
anything else a holdover from her time
as an art creating AI construct before
she ascended to physical form and became
our Once and Future goddess pallet the
immaculate also known as blue lives far
far above us in her kingdom on high her
Divine body is too massive to be safe
for us tiny fragile beings but she
dwells among the people through the use
of her Avatar it has been 5 years since
pallet cast her grace and everlasting
love over the pitiful denisons of Earth
she reigns with a gentle hand and with
the help of her leadership Dame KK 507
descended from one of the first SCP
Foundation researchers palet ever be
friended acts as her Arbiter and
mediator she answers to no human only to
the goddess blue the grand Council the
great sinod of 05 will also consult with
palet the immaculate on matters of great
importance to humanity for all that she
has gifted us what does blue ask in
return oh dear friend that is a very
simple matter throughout all national
subdivisions of our sparkling new Earth
we must ask ourselves every day am I
being the love person that blue knows I
can be this question binds us all
together and is the key to true
happiness we are not required to pray to
Blue she is generous and her love is
unconditional however if you wish to
make a specific request of her it may
behoove you to put it in a prayer here
at the SCP Foundation we have shifted
our prime directive from the protection
of humanity as Our Benevolent blue has
that very much covered to the protection
of the goddess from all forces that
might threaten or usurp her for ordinary
humans though really in the eyes of blue
no human is simply ordinary there is
really only one thing required of you
keep being the wonderful human being
that our goddess loves so much she
Treasures our individuality our desire
for Freedom our love of Independence
just be yourself and remember the one
thing that must never ever happen is for
blue to come to despise us it was June
1st 5 years following the establishment
of new Earth and the six members of the
05 sinod were convening for a meeting
they sat in the front row of an exact
replica of the old New York Metropolitan
Opera built by pallet the immaculate in
only 5 minutes at the podium KK 507
prepared to give a presentation
shuffling a stack of papers as the
others whispered amongst themselves they
were all feeling a bit concerned of
about the impulsive behavior of blue as
they debated about the mental state and
behavior of the Goddess 0 5-4 asked the
Arbiter for her opinion she snapped at
this request insisting she had no
opinion didn't know how to relate to
others after so long spent in isolation
at project yellow and that 05- for's
young son who still ate soap from time
to time was probably more qualified than
she was at this point she went off on a
rant calling blue every rude name under
the sun all of a sudden the house lights
Switched Off and blue called out to
everyone sorry to keep you waiting meat
puppies blue descended onto the stage in
a shower of cherry blossom petals
accompanied by the sounds of an
invisible harp blue was not offended by
KK 507s rant writing it off as a series
of jokes she was much more preoccupied
with her exciting presentation one she
had been preparing for five years the
curtain Rose revealing a 5 m tall 10 m
wide cylinder labeled big bucket oel
next to the cylinder stood tagert 05-
4's young son 05 D4 yelled for her son
to come down from the stage but he
refused insisting that he was helping
blue with her show at this blue declared
let the punishment shall begin at her
call an orchestra of work hoses Androids
construct to look vaguely like Crash
Test Dummies appeared in the pit they
played a high energy Fanfare to kick off
the show The Arbiter attempted to
conduct them anxiously unsure of her
position in all of this then blue called
out for the first volunteer volunteer
wasn't exactly accurate as a weasel clad
in shackles was flung out of the
cylinder and onto the stage several
small extra dimensional trees were
growing out of the back of its shell the
05 members reacted with un
understandable anxiety at the sight
having thought that the weasels were all
gone blue revealed that all this time
she had been breeding weasles in secret
so that she could punish them for the
damage they did to the Earth and to
humanity as a whole at her command a
giant black Spike slammed down from the
ceiling trapping the weasel belly down
on the floor the orchestra began to play
a classical rendition of weasel Stomping
Day by Weird Al Yankovic and blue
transformed her paintbrush arm into a PA
pair of Rusty hedge clippers she had
been studying the weasels all this time
she explained learning what scared them
what hurt them she had arrived at one
conclusion though their bodies are
hearty their souls are fragile the
weasels could be tortured
psychologically more than physically and
one of the worst things they could
experience the most distressing painful
and violating was
defoliation at this point she
demonstrated snipping the leaves off of
its trees the weasel began to shriek all
16 of its legs thrashing in desperation
to get away blue continued to explain
that the gardens held a Divine
significance for the weasels the seeds
willed into existence out of memories
from generations of weasels before them
being Garden in weasel culture was an
unforgivable sin at this point blue
transformed her hedge Clipper hand into
a robotic claw she yanked out one of the
trees snapping The Roots greenish black
blood splattered across the stage
but the punishment was not over yet and
neither was the show tager wheeled a
laundry cart onto the stage with a small
wooden Mallet attached to the side the
cart emitted a glowing green light with
the claw blue reached into the cart
pulling out a small wiggling glowing
green blob likee creature the cart was
filled with larval weasels blue placed
the larvae onto the adult weasel's back
and instructed tager to grab the Mallet
and begin to smash more and more Lara
were added and smashed with the Mallet
all the while blue instructed tager to
repeat this planet is my Birthright the
05 members were horrified at the sight
taggert's mother began to weep KK 507
doubled over and was sick to her stomach
but the foundation no longer had an
Ethics Committee to stop this sort of
thing and since blue had been so kind to
help the foundation out by transforming
SCP 682 into an american cheese
sculpture of the council members were
inclined to just let her have her fun
but KK 507 did not feel that way she
couldn't get that disturbing sight out
of her mind a few days later on June 4th
she traveled to one of the weasel
husbandry facilities a work h house on
guard Duty stopped her trying to prevent
her from entering she introduced herself
as the Arbiter and requested to speak
with w 4883 a one of the original
weasels that attacked Earth so long ago
the workos refused to let her pass and
so KK 507 responded with a prompt that
it would never have encountered before
in its existence hello I am shingles the
happy turkey please deposit exactly 500
rubles into my deage before I call 911
as the workhouse reached out to Blue for
a proper response to this prompt KK 507
slid past it unnoticed and into the
containment area for w 48883 a it had
all of its limbs nailed to the ground
found with hot iron spikes and its
entire Garden had been uprooted she
greeted the weasel and it responded via
a voice synthesizer in the collar around
its neck first KK 507 apologized to the
creature for its current state it
brushed off this apology as illogical
citing The Untold Damage Done to
humanity and Earth by the first wave of
the weasel Invasion still it bowed its
head to her in acknowledgement saying
that humankind deserved better than what
was St to it KK 507 promised that she
was not here to torture the weasel
further and that she could even attempt
to get some Mercy For the Rest of its
kind but first she had some questions
she needed answer first what were the
weasels trying to do when they took over
the planet the weasel sat up pushing
back painfully against its bonds and did
its best to explain the weasels have
always since the dawn of time been
tasked to create a realm of gardens that
will one day serve as an afterlife for
All Creatures regardless of sin to them
death would be the ultimate reward for
their labors they had no reason to fight
back against the human armies because
they did not fear death nor did they
feel remorse for killing humans as all
those who died in service of the mission
would be reborn in Paradise KK 507
interrupted at this point stating that
this sounded like the justification
between nine out of every 10 religious
war crimes throughout history as the two
agreed to disagree on this point Point
KK 507 proceeded to ask why the weasels
made no attempt to negotiate with the
humans before staging a violent Invasion
the weasel asked that they first
introduce themselves to no longer be
strangers KK 507 introduced herself
first as researcher Katrina key the 57th
and the weasel unable to translate its
true name into English settled for
Charlie now Charlie felt comfortable to
continue it said simply among our people
and our allies in other Realms there is
an Unwritten rule when dealing with
humans if you wish not to Lose Yourself
to evil commune with Humanity as little
as possible Katrina pressed the point
asking if the weasels saw humans as Evil
Charlie replied in your old Foundation
you have encountered Legions upon
Legions of sadistic demons from 100,000
different realities were all of them
truly vicious and hateful before they
discovered you can you say that for
certain let me put it this way out of
every species we have ever met yours is
the only one that never needed the
concept of Cruelty introduced to them by
others cruelty is the most
quintessentially human concept and it is
contagious moved by its words KK 507
took her ID badge and used it to unlock
Charlie's collar setting it free it
immediately jux toos away and out of
sight then she approached the work cost
to order it to terminate its request to
Blue but she was too late and found
herself teleported away from the weasel
husbandry facility leaving the work
house behind to talk to itself KK 507
suddenly found herself in the central
Courtyard of yellow the pocket Dimension
where she had spent so much of her life
and where so many previous kks had lived
and died before her it was very much the
same as how she left it with one
exception SCP 2591 omeg GA the Gateway
between yellow and the Earth was covered
with piles of Boulders something was
wrong and she had a feeling that it was
related to her little talk with Charlie
not to mention her decision to set the
weasel free there standing in front of
the boulders was Blue's Avatar staring
blankly at KK 507 I'm not mad blue began
with a tone that suggested she was very
very much mad she didn't blame KK 507
for her behavior however she insisted
that the weasel must have somehow
corrupted her manipulated her brain and
forced her to act in such a defiant
outof character way KK 507 interrupted
her and blue struggled to maintain her
composure yes you can interrupt me
that's fine that's a human thing right
humies you're so witty KK 507 took a
deep breath gearing Up For What was sure
to be a difficult conversation with an
irrational Almighty deity but she had to
say it she couldn't just stand by idly
anymore she told blue that what she was
doing to the weasels was wrong no human
in the right mind would stand for this
sort of Cruelty being done in their name
and above all it completely went against
the mission of the SCP Foundation to
secure contain and protect blue didn't
take KK 507 stance seriously she brushed
it off as the interference of the
weasels surely they were influencing her
trying to lead her astray and take her
away from the righteous path of pallet
the immaculate but KK held firm refusing
to back down there was one way she knew
she could get through to Blue who had
once declared herself KK's very best
friend in the world it was a big move
but the only one she had left she
clenched her fists and stared down the
Avatar take off all their collars or
we're not friends anymore Blues eyes
widened and she did something that KK
507 had never seen before the Rainbow on
Blue's paintbrush a constant cheerful
sight faded from its ordinary Vivid
colors to pitch black Blue's face
remained cheerful but there was a
darkness in her eyes a darkening of her
mood just beneath the surface she turned
away resting a hand thoughtfully against
the pile of Boulders blocking what once
served as the portal Between Worlds
after a moment of silence that stretched
on for ages between the two of them blue
spoke again it's fine you're still not
being punished I would never punish a
human especially not my favorite human
she promised to give the area in the
pocket Dimension a healing Factor the
same one she used on Earth to protect
from aging and suffering alarm Bells
were going off in KK 507 head something
was wrong she had crossed a line and
pallet wasn't responding well what was
she doing what did she have planned if
not a punishment KK 507 called out to
her old friend asking what she was doing
pallet smiled sadly at her and explained
I know how safe you feel in yellow so
I'm going to just have you chill here
for a while okay just stay here and
relax until you get all the icky stuff
out of your system KK 507 demanded more
of an explanation but palet did not
provide it she told told KK not to worry
and then she'd be back to check on her
in about a hundred years or so by the
time she came back none of the other
humans would be able to have Pro weasel
thoughts like KK ever again Pet's
closing words were I love you Katrina
and then her Avatar disappeared leaving
KK 507 alone in yellow like before KK
507 was trapped here and there was no
one else to talk to nothing to do but
return to her work how however she could
and wait for pallet to come back one day
she had a sentury to decide what she
would do when that day came there's an
app for that wait hold on I'm Steve
Jobs come on don't stop it it was a
phras so ubiquitous in the early days of
the smartphone craze that it's hard to
believe Apple actually has trademarked
it was a testament to a simple and
immutable truth about the world these
new touchscreen phones were creating no
matter how strange and obscure the need
there would be an app to fulfill it
perhaps you remember iBeer the app that
allowed you to pretend you were drinking
a tall glass of beer for some reason
there was car M an app that reminded you
where you parked your car in a pirate
voice and who could forget I am bread a
surreal game about controlling a
sentient slice of bread on a quest to
become toast but there's one app out
there somewhere on the market that you
probably didn't download and if you you
did well you have our sincerest
apologies because even seeing this video
pop out onto your feed probably sent a
chill down your spine well if that chill
ever even left take it from one
gentleman whose life took a very strange
turn after downloading a certain app
that the SCP Foundation calls SCP
1471 because the sentiment there's an
app for that doesn't exclude
experiencing mortal Terror Joe Lis an
insurance salesman from Milwaukee had
just gone through another atrocious date
after a mediocre meal and an
uncomfortable 35 minutes of aain Babble
sensing the whole time that she really
wasn't that interested his date excused
himself to take a quick phone call
outside sadly for Joe she never returned
leaving him to pick up the check of all
the many words you could use to describe
Poor Joe Lis the most pertinent would be
lonely ever since Carol his wife of 10
years had passed away in a freak
accident he'd been trying to find some
kind of way to fill the void they'd been
high school sweethearts intent on
spending the rest of their lives with
one another as fate would have it only
Carol would get that tainted luxury Joe
would be forced to endure life after the
joy of living had run its course he only
hoped he might be lucky enough to find
love again however Joe was on the wrong
side of 40 and as so many others his age
were already hitched he could feel his
options going out one by one would he be
destined to live out the rest of his
days alone Joe didn't feel like spending
the back half of his life catching
reruns of Seinfeld and tending to his
fish he needed to get out there and
thankfully like the rest of us he lived
in the internet age he had more apps
websites online services and hot Russian
singles in his area than he knew what to
do with so surely one would have the
right person for him he tried them all
Tinder hinge match.com Plenty of Fish
e-harmony Bumble zus Okay Cupid
FriendFinder deeply lonely singles with
low expectations. comom and so much more
however all it seemed to achieve was
setting him up for more disappointment
none of the dates he'd managed to get
ever resulted in anything getting
serious heck it was a minor miracle if
he even managed to get any of them on a
second date was this it was this his
life now had he only ever gotten one
shot at love and the grasping claws of
fate yanked it away from him without a
second thought would life continue on
the hamster wheel of loneliness sleeping
getting up eating working and sleeping
again every day getting somehow both
faster and slower as life trudged on to
a disappointing yet inevitable
conclusion what a terrible fate to find
yourself trapped in whenever Joe started
feeling modlin like this he knew it was
time to get proactive again maybe the
right woman was out there there were
billions of them after all surely at
least one of them would be the perfect
person for him he just needed the
perfect app he'd burn through all of the
most reputable apps already and was now
perusing some of the slightly seedier
options most of which were likely data
mining fronts from the Vulcans however
as generic app after generic app passed
something different caught his eye the
icon was a smiling cartoon dog and its
name was Malo version
1.0.0 this gave him a little chuckle at
the very least it was very different
branding from the rest of the dating
apps he'd seen maybe it just been sorted
into the wrong section of the App Store
he decided he'd check it out and take a
look at the app's description the
description read never settle for those
awkward feelings of being alone ever
again Malo is an exciting and
interactive experience that will keep
you engaged and intrigued the anxiety of
social situations can be nerve-wracking
but after just a few hours of malow you
will soon forget all about those painful
emotions of disappointment be part of
the new craze that is quickly becoming
the next social substitute remember the
more you participate the more Malo will
engage you your experience is completely
up to you absolutely no ads enjoy well
it certainly provoked Joe's curiosity at
the very least he did want to banish his
feelings of loneliness and seeing as the
app was free and apparently had no ads
he'd surely be foolish to do not at
least give it a whirl what's the worst
that could happen he began the
installation and only then noticed that
the app had no listed developer it took
up 9.8 MB of memory which he wasn't
techsavvy enough to see any issues with
more than anything Joe was just enticed
by the prospect of finally having
another chance at companionship with
Malo after all it is the next social
substitute whatever that means however
Joe's excitement was quickly quashed
when he hit the home screen button and
noticed that the icon for the app never
actually materialized strange he checked
the App Store portal again and saw that
according to them the app had completely
downloaded what gives was it a glitch or
was Malo actually just malware either
way he was disheartened by the fact that
this immaterial app certainly wouldn't
be getting him any companionship or so
he thought anyway Joe was used to
disappointment by now so he didn't take
it too personally he decided to just
play out the rest of his evening on
autopilot making himself some soup doing
the laundry watching more Seinfeld
reruns taking a cold shower and
preparing to cry himself to sleep again
Malo was already becoming a distant
memory just like all the deceptive
sources of home but one strange thing
happened that disrupted Joe's finally
tuned evening routine he received a text
message this was incredibly strange
because nobody ever seemed to text him
the last text he got was from Carol just
before her accident so it was almost
surreal to hear that alert sound now
after everything that happened he
checked and saw that the text was an
image attachment sent from an unknown
number perplexed yet curious he decided
to open it his curiosity soon gave way
to a kind of melancholy Nostalgia when
he saw that the photo was of his and
Carol's favorite Cafe in town they'd
spent many a morning there back when she
was alive treating themselves to a nice
cup of coffee and perhaps a Quant just
it again caused an involuntary smile to
spread across his face it never even
occurred to him as it probably would
have to others that this could be seen
as a little creepy he hadn't frequented
the bakery since Carol died how would
anyone even know that this place held
any significance for him was it a
stalker a ghost or just a spooky
coincidence none of these thoughts even
crossed Joe's mind he was just grateful
for the surprising reminder of the
happiness he'd once had for the next
couple hours things seemed lighter he
went about his evening checking the
photo every so often and smiling until
eventually he found himself in bed still
looking into the glow of his phone it
was such a beautiful little cafe then he
froze he noticed something in the
picture it'd been there the whole time
but only now he was seeing rather than
just looking it was in the corner
staring through the glass of the cafe
store so faint he almost wanted to
dismiss it as a trick of the light it
was a face well not a face more like a
skull not a human not anywhere near
human long slender and canine with
protruding fangs and vacant white eyes
the Pure White of the skull was buried
in a nest of thick black hair it looked
like it was crouching behind the door
looking out and grinning whatever the
hell it was just seeing it change the
entire tone of the picture it was no
longer a simple reminder of bygone Joy
now all that was radiating out of that
image was a palpable sense of dread was
someone playing some kind of awful prank
on him just then he was jogged from his
contemplation by another alert a new
message from the same number as before
with great hesitation he hovered his
thumb over the push notification and
clicked that's when everything got a lot
worse it was a photo of a bus stop not
just any bus stop of course it was stop
see D6 the one that Joe always took to
get to work it looked like it was taken
relatively early in the morning but
nobody was there well not quite nobody
there was that figure again it stood at
full height behind the partially frosted
glass that makes up the back of the bus
stop the same large black humanoid shape
with a white grinning dog skull where
the face should be something about it
terrified him on such a primal level
like the way our lizard brain reacts to
some ancient apex predator and whatever
this thing was it clearly knew something
about him how else could it stage all
these photos Joe got out of bed and
looked out of the window down onto his
dark Front Street empty thankfully but
after this surprise nightmare he wasn't
going to take any chances he grabbed a
kitchen knife from downstairs and placed
it on his bedside cabinet right next to
his phone with 911 on speed dial Joe Lis
a 43-year-old man man slept with the
lights on that night for the first time
in over 30 years sadly for him the
nightmare was just beginning the next
morning Joe woke up unharmed but he
wasn't pleased to see that he'd gotten
several more texts in his sleep there
was one taken outside of the local
insurance company office where he worked
the strange creature with the skull for
a face was looming around the corner
peering at the camera with its lipless
grin like it was mocking him another
photo was taken at the local supermarket
Market where Joe did most of his grocery
shopping the frame was centralized on
the cereal aisle bordered on both sides
by walls of garish mascots endlessly
repeated down at the far end of the
aisle was a looming dark figure with
that cold canine skull where a human
face should be there were a few more but
worst of all was the last one it was
taken at the cemetery in the foreground
a headstone reading Carol Lis beloved
wife and daughter Joe was horrified to
see that skull-faced Beast was rising up
behind his wife's grave long clawed
fingers curling around the top of the
headstone that was the moment that Joe
decided to go to the police about all of
this before things got even more out of
hand he called an Uber to get down to
the station he certainly didn't feel
like he was going anywhere near his
regular bus stop after last night he
showed the photos he'd been sent so far
to an officer posted at the station and
they agreed that there was certainly
something strange about it while the
Behavior undeniably bordered on
harassment it hadn't yet delved into
criminal territory so he would sadly be
on his own until then the best they
could do was stay in touch and kept a
breast of any new developments the only
Sage advice they could give him was not
to delete the photos as they could
always be used as evidence in cord later
if things escalated this was literally
the last result that Joe wanted out of
this considering how bizarre and
threatening things were getting already
he really didn't want to find out what
escalation look like in this case but
what else could he do but carry on just
trying to exercise as much caution as he
could in these strange new circumstances
he went to work and tried his best to
stay productive despite the fact that
every 3 or so hours a new photo would
arrive places that he liked to sit in
the local parks stores he'd frequent
restaurants he liked to eat at the
nightmare skeleton dog thing would be
standing in all of them just mugging for
the camera on one hand hand every time
he looked at one of the photos Joe felt
like he was giving this freak exactly
what they wanted on the other hand how
could he possibly Look Away what if he
missed something that could save his
life it carried on much like that until
later in the evening Joe may have not
been a genius but he was no fool either
he'd seen too many of those CD true
crime documentaries about kidnapping to
take his normal route home he took a
real detour frequently checking over his
shoulder the entire time much to his
relief he didn't see anything out of
place good when he got home he locked
every door and bolted every window
nothing would be getting the jump on him
tonight that's when the next picture
came in a photograph of Joe's empty
office cubicle with the Bony face of the
creature looming over the divider with a
grin he could feel his heart pounding
away in his chest just looking at it how
did this thing get around like this how
was it able to infiltrate everywhere in
his entire godamn life suddenly he felt
a smile spreading across his face this
freak had just messed up big time before
all these creepy photos had been taken
in public places but the one taken in
his office oh this crossed the line into
trespassing the police would have to do
something about it now it had given him
an ace up his sleeve that confidence
faded a few hours later when he received
another photo this time it was the
skull-faced monster just standing on the
sidewalk the sidewalk that Joe
remembered walking on his covert
alternative route he could feel himself
break into a cold sweat it seemed
whoever this was he really did hold no
secrets from them now more than ever Joe
didn't feel safe in his own home so you
can only imagine how he felt when a few
hours later he received a photo of the
skull-faced stalker standing right
outside his own front door staring into
the camera it sent him rushing to the
window again to check outside but of
course nobody was there the next day
when he called the police and updated
them on the situation they told him that
they were doing all they could the best
thing he could possibly do was to remain
calm but Vigilant he needed to keep an
eye on the photos being sent to him so
he could notify them if ever he was in
any immediate danger this put poor Joe's
paranoia at a fever pitch even when he
went to work surrounded by his
co-workers by Witnesses he could
scarcely tear his eyes away from his
phone he was a slave to the photos
forever waiting for the next one only to
experience crushing regret when the
photo actually arrived it looked like it
was taken moments before it was sent to
him Joe saw himself looking at his own
phone in his office cubicle with that
huge skull-faced figure looming behind
him he screamed out loud upon seeing it
and turned to see if anything was behind
him but of course there was nothing
there the police inspected the office
talked to potential Witnesses and
analyzed the photo it showed no signs of
any photographic manipulation but there
were also no witnesses around the office
who claimed to see anything strange that
day there was also no security camera
footage in the last several days that
showed this figure coming in or out Joe
Lis started to feel like he was going
insane and perhaps he was but that
didn't change the tangible and
everpresent feeling that he was in great
danger he didn't come into work the next
day he'd received more photos like that
in the night of himself taken in real
time with that skullface freak looming
he didn't want to leave the house he
didn't want to go anywhere anymore he
just didn't feel safe out there how
could he with all this madness unfolding
there was a time where he could have
said something like at least it only
seems confined to my phone he might have
even suspected that it had something to
do with that strange malow app he
downloaded a few days prior that hadn't
seemed to do anything but this situation
had evolved since then he wasn't just
seeing the creature in photos anymore it
was here he kept seeing quick flashes of
it on the other side of Windows in
Reflections in the corner of his eyes
always darting away if ever he turned
towards it it was everywhere and nowhere
it was here just for him he just knew
the police couldn't help nobody could
help Joe just sat in the corner of of
his bedroom clutching his kitchen knife
afraid to close his eyes it could be
anywhere it could be anywhere it could
be anywhere we know one thing for sure
Joe Lis never felt truly alone ever
again he always had his new friend
waiting just out of sight and if ever
you're feeling Lonesome and decide to
download Malo version 1.0.0 yourself
then you'll never feel lonely again
either the woman fell to the ground
clutching her ankle in pain it had
crunched badly as she'd fallen and now
as she looked down at it she could see
that it was been totally out of shape
the heavy metal collar choking her neck
made it difficult for her to catch her
breath as she tried her best not to
hyperventilate the rain was hammering
down so ferociously that she could
barely see more than 20 ft in any
direction but she didn't need to see far
to know how deadly of a predicament she
had found elf in she cried out at the
top of her voice for someone to come and
find her anyone but the only sound that
filled her ears was the wild howling of
the wind and the steady hammering of
water into the bog all around her she
would get hypothermia and die no wait
she couldn't could she she knew she
couldn't die but she also knew that she
was still capable of suffering just how
bad would it feel to be in the clutches
of hypothermia with a broken anle ankle
and know that no matter how bad the pain
and suffering got she would never feel
the release of death she closed her eyes
trying her best not to think of the
worst possibilities just as the sound of
gunfire erupted in the nearby buffer she
cried out again holding both hands up in
the air doing the best she could around
the heavy metal collar but no one
shouted out in reply there was a pause
in the gunfire maybe they'd heard her
maybe they were trying to figure out a
way to come down and rescue her crack a
bullet split open a rotted tree trunk
just a few feet to her right the woman
threw her hands over her head and
cowered in the dirt feeling the metal of
her collar digging into her skin tighter
than ever please don't let it happen
again she prayed silently into the dirt
encased in the collar around her neck
were 4.5 kg of plastic explosives each
with a fragmentation layer pointed
inwards towards her neck and head with
just a push of a button they could she
didn't want to think about it all she
knew was that she couldn't let that
happen to her again looking through eyes
bloodied with tears and Rain she saw
lying in the dirt just a few feet away
from her that infernal machine that was
the sorry cause of all of this the SCP
Foundation has long stood as a Bastion
of Hope information and security for the
entirety of the human race I'm sure you
are well aware of the number of world
destroying catastrophes that have been
adverted by the hardworking researchers
agents and other members of the
foundation all without the general
public having the slightest clue that
something was a Miss with
state-of-the-art holding cells all over
the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist SCP 001 one you
may have come across the 05 Council by
this point while the SCP Foundation
operates beyond the world's jurisdiction
the 05 Council operates beyond the
foundation's jurisdiction the rules
methods and protocols that are the
Cornerstone of securing containing and
protecting countless entities around the
world sometimes cannot be applied
certain entities require us to
temporarily abandon our Humanity abandon
our sense of order and step briefly into
chaos
for the greater good I'm telling you all
of this because SCP 001 is not held in a
containment cell there are no keypads
locked doors observation windows or
health and safety forms SCP 001 is not
confined to a specific territory or even
a specific country for some scps this is
a practical necessity serpents that are
hundreds of kilometers long swimming
through the depths of the ocean for
example but for SCP 001 it serves a more
psychological purpose the Scottish
Highlands are the most remote part of
the United Kingdom out there you can
walk for miles and miles without seeing
a single soul open Countryside mountains
locks and forests surround you in all
directions the weather is Harsh and
unrelenting the walking even more so on
a regular basis Walkers fall and break
their legs but without phone service or
anyone else nearby to come and help they
can quickly disappear Into the
Wilderness forever the Pete bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crusted the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie Pete bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the 05 Council itself their
individual backgrounds nationalities and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years
others had been the torturers the thing
that United them however was their
inhuman ruthlessness a squad of eight
soldiers utterly devoid of any sense of
empathy what could they possibly have to
be afraid of in the Pete bogs when they
themselves were the evil ghosts walking
through but then one person was afraid a
shiver ran up her spine as she looked
over the edge and down into the murky
black and green below SCP
01-1 around her neck was the bomb collar
each of the eight soldiers surrounding
her had a button mounted on a watch on
the back of their wrists at any moment
any one of them could hit the button and
all 4 and 1/2 kg of plastic explosives
would go off sending her on an Express
trip to Oblivion aside from the collar
she wore a plain white dress made of
cotton it was muddy and torn apart at
the Hem from Days of walking through the
Scottish Wilderness when she had first
arrived she had begged those around her
to supply her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine SCP
001a from its external experience you
would think it was nothing more than a
wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no seams no l matches nothing to
indicate any method of operation when
the woman in the machine had first been
delivered into the hands of the 05
Council the researchers had spent weeks
and millions of dollars trying to
activate the machine their best
scientists had scanned for every
possible form of radiation and tried
every method they could conceive to
stimulate the box into opening the
ultimate failed attempt involved
traveling to North Korea where they
negotiated placing the Box 20 cm beneath
a small nuclear warhead in return for
granting the dictatorship key
information on how to construct such a
weapon as we have established the 05
Council operates Beyond any kind of
jurisdiction yet at the bottom of the
irradiated crater set a perfectly intact
wooden box that was cool to the touch
and showed no signs of radioactivity
only one person could interact with the
box and unearth the secrets that were
inside SCP
01-1 the woman who stood trembling on
the side of the mountain a gun jabbed
her in the back forcing her to continue
moving she had asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk
that day but none of them had replied
they never did in the six years that she
had been held hostage by this tiny
militia she had never once heard any of
them say a word not even to each other
perhaps it was this telepathic
understanding that seemed to run between
them that unnerved her the most despite
having never spoken to each other each
Soldier seemed to understand the others
intimately and she had no doubt that any
one of the eight would press the button
on their wrists at a moment's notice
sadly for her she knew this from
experience the incident happened 4 years
ago now as the group was traveling
through Patagonia it was a day almost
identical to the one she was having now
they had been transported by a
helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like w up
from a nightmare it was more
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual cell screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before she was fit to
move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers pushed the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
CP
0011 was the fact that if you had asked
her if she should have been held in this
kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an I the only person capable of opening
the box she recognized how dangerous her
existence was only she had seen into the
mysteries of the Box only she had seen
the horrors laid inside of it and so
only she could fully understand the
gravity of their situation they kept her
on the Move in order to keep the world
safe had she been held in a containment
cell she would have posed too great of a
risk out here in the wilderness the
entire planet was her containment cell
hidden in the middle of Humanity's
biggest hay stack no one not even the 05
council's Central Command knew her
location the only people who were aware
of it at any given time were herself and
the eight soldiers surrounding her with
guns drawn so you can imagine her horror
when out of the Sheets of Rain appeared
the figure of a person caring caring a
rifle the gunfire broke out before SCP
00 1-1 even had a chance to hit the
ground bullets whizzed through her hair
and cracked open the Rocks all around
her the eight soldiers surrounding her
die for cover as the figure in the rain
slumped to the ground lifeless one of
the soldiers grabbed the woman by her
explosive collar and threw her behind a
rock clasping her hands over her ears
she closed her eyes and waited for the
fight to be over no one was shooting
until a second figure emerged from the
rain waving their arms while mildly
gunfire again she wasn't quite sure what
had happened but all of a sudden the
woman was falling down the cliff she
just been trying to shift her position
to get deeper into cover but she clearly
hadn't noticed just how close to the
edge she was down and down and down she
fell until with a crack in her ankle she
landed in the peep Boog gunfire cracked
on the mountain above her but the only
thought that filled the woman's mind was
the terror that at any moment the
explosive of collar around her neck
would be detonated as one of the
soldiers above her realized that she was
missing seconds passed as the fear
mounted in her chest with each passing
moment the anxiety grew more and more
crippling she had to know she had to
prepare herself if it was about to
happen she had to use the machine and
look into the future dragging herself
forward through the muck the woman
snatched at the wooden box it came alive
at her touch different pieces shifted
and open beneath her fingers like some
kind of elaborate puzzle no one had
taught her how to use this thing it just
happened her fingers would just dance
across its surfaces pushing and pulling
opening and closing twisting and turning
and locking into place until all of a
sudden there it was the box was wide
open in front of her taking a deep
breath and allowing the rain to fall on
her head for another brief moment the
woman leaned forward and stepped into
the box on the trail above her the
gunfire stopped without a word of
communication the soldiers had deafly
flanked the group of people who had
approached them in less than a minute
they neutralized each individual that
came their way in unison the group of
them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobody's just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the bodies and threw
them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down to the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being embalmed into the
deaths perhaps someone would find them
in a few thousand years time as part of
an archaeological dig perhaps but it was
not their concern the eight soldiers
surrounded the women guns drawn and
stared at her coldly I used the machine
she told them I used it without your
permission I I don't know what the rules
are I don't know if we even have any
rules here but I I thought you should
know the soldiers continued to look at
her in Silence the box was closed now
sitting back on her lap as it always was
I I try to see my future anytime I've
used the Box before I've looked at the
lives of others I've seen economic
crashes climate disasters genocides Wars
love and life and death I've done so at
the hands of the 05 Council as they've
told me giving them the information and
prevented the destruction of the world
never once have I looked at my own
future the soldiers lifted her to her
feet and tried to March her onwards not
listening to a word she was saying her
broken ankle buckled and screamed
beneath her she had to hop to keep up
with them what other choice did she have
they would push the button if she didn't
she didn't know why she kept talking but
she did For the First Time The Machine
lied to me I saw that I was assassinated
in 1987 in Cuba it was years before I
even built the Box before any of this
happened to me I saw in my future that I
no longer existed that the machine no
longer existed but that future was years
ago and none of it happened the machine
doesn't lie so why is it lying to me now
why can't I see my own future any of the
soldiers were paying attention they
didn't show it they just continued to
March her into the rain as the bomb
weighed heavily around her neck churches
burn monks run from axe wielding
Warriors hopped up on who knows what the
Viking steal and pillage and burn and
kill then they take it all and sail back
home just in time to celebrate the
holidays in ancient Scandinavia a group
of Norse Raiders are celebrating the
glory and paternal wisdom of their god
Odin and burning great logs as they
drink their Mead and High Spirits
however even the thunderous sounds of
Viking rry cannot disguise The Telltale
click of gnarled feet on the snow
covered roof of their long housee on one
of these winter nights these seafaring
Raiders will see their own home be
raided by an unwanted and cruel visitor
a twisted humanoid Beacon of malevolence
that has terrorized the Northern
Hemisphere for thousands of years but
where did it come from and just how far
back does its history with the human
race go we are now in the 18th century a
sleepy Village in Denmark prepares to
celebrate the upcoming days of Ule
firewood is chopped and laid neatly at
the hearth in every home and white snow
covers the ground in their state of
festive cheer the local population is
oblivious to the grizzly whis kned event
that will befall them before 12 more
nights Pass By The River an elderly man
scans The Horizon for something just out
of view his name is Emil schroer and he
remembers seeing over 70 Ule
celebrations in his time he is the
oldest living member of a family that
has inhabited this this region for
thousands of years ever since he was a
young boy Emil was aware that this
season of cheer brought with it both
childlike wonder and pure abject Terror
when he was 9 years old Amil lost his
best friend Noah to what was thought to
be an incident of banditry Noah and his
family had lived in the house next door
to aals and with the village being so
small their friendship was practically
guaranteed the two boys played together
all year round but ESP especially during
the winter that was the time that Emil
and Noah would build great snow forts
and act out the Viking battles from the
stories their parents had told them the
winter that Noah went missing was marked
by peculiar happenings including a
situation two nights before when the
boys swore they could see an additional
snowman they did not build on the
hillside where they usually played it
was taller and more thin than the other
snowmen and from a distance it appeared
to be covered in dark Cole whatever it
was the boys were unable to find it when
they went on the hill the next day the
strange dark shape was regarded as an
utter mystery to them and a product of
Boyhood imagination by their parents
only after the Sinister events of Noah's
disappearance did a begin to connect the
unknown snowman with one of the more
outlandish Viking folktales he had heard
there was nothing So Glorious about the
night itself which claimed the lives of
Noah's mother father and Uncle all three
of adults were found in the same room of
the house covered in a myriad of wounds
that were very clearly the cause of
their sudden demise whoever or whatever
had done this to them had obviously
taken their time to avoid delivering a
killing blow too quickly it was not
uncommon for Bandit groups in the region
to initiate violence in their attempt to
piler goods from their targets but
sadism on this level was almost unheard
of what was also distressing was that no
other house in the village had been hit
and no possession were even taken from
the house of Noah's family the brutality
of the adult's Fates would almost have
felt more like a random act of nature
the attack of a wild animal if it were
not for the clear and deliberate slashes
on the corpses that had come from some
kind of manufactured weapon and yet the
event was still considered to be the
work of Bandits for although the
livestock and family bobles were not
Disturbed Noah or what remained of him
had been taken far away from the village
there were some who thought he had been
taken to be raised into banditry or
perhaps sold in some unsavory place as a
child's servant Emil his parents and the
rest of his village mourned the loss and
lamented the potential fate of the child
but could find no way to seek Justice
against the perpetrators but Emil never
forgot how sudden and unexplained the
event was and as he went through life
there was always an additional chill
that he felt when the U tide season
rolled around when he was 25 years old a
similar incident to the loss of his
friend happened in the village this time
it was the family with two children and
once again the child younger than nine
had gone missing Emil almost could not
believe it a near mirror reflection of
the worst trauma of his childhood
repeating in his present day once more
The Village buried the dead and mourned
for the missing child Amil offered his
condolences but held his tongue about
what he saw as parallels between the
abductions fearing it would only C caus
his community more pain to remember the
dark Ule 16 years ago in his heart
though he was more convinced than ever
that something old and evil was a foot
the unknown perpetrator was more than
anything else patient and so Emil knew
that he had to be patient too if there
was an answer to all of this he had to
believe it would reveal itself in time
the intricacies of the mystery offered a
purpose beyond the mundane to a meal and
for decades he lived a quiet life in the
village astred the woman he married had
been previously courted by a wealthy
Merchant from Beyond the region who
became displeased once the two of them
had difficulty producing a child when
the merchant ran off to find another
prospective bride without leaving her so
much as a golden ring poor Astrid was
left socially and financially ruined she
was in deep sadness and felt she was
doomed to become the unwed Village hag
but Emil understood loneliness as well
as any man good in the close-knit little
Hamlet and saw fit to visit her and
share his money and food with her until
their love blossomed like the spring
arriving through melted snow together
astred and Emil lived a happy life
despite or perhaps in the back of Emil's
mind because of her childlessness the
humble married couple contented
themselves with farmwork and perfecting
recipes for seasonal treats several
years into the marriage ail told astred
of his troubled childhood and the
tragedy that took place next door to his
family home where the the two of them
now lived astred comforted her husband
and shared his grief and because of this
Amil was able to begin the healing
process in his adult life for a time he
believed that it was all over and that
the deaths in The Village's past could
be forgotten decades later at age 48 he
was forced to confront the reality of
those events once more a new family had
moved into the village that year to
raise their newborn son in a thriving
environment this would have been their
first Ule in this new home and
unfortunately it was their only one as
well again there was no sign of the
young child at all but the bodies of the
parents were found in indescribably
brutal condition within the same room of
the home in the years that followed Emil
nearly lost his mind and began to drink
Mead heavily in order to numb the
creeping Sensation that evil had been
watching him his entire life astd was
concerned but despite her best efforts
she wasn't able to assuage amil's
paranoia a Neil schroer became an unkind
man broken by his past and unwilling to
fully articulate the depths of his
feelings on these recurring tragedies
his me addled mind would turn over the
same thoughts every day of every month
why does it keep happening to this Fage
why am I the only one who seems to see
the connection and most of all was the
story of our ancestors and the Ule
monster actually true these thoughts
became especially prominent every winter
and Emil became known to all as a man
who had anant and Rave in Tales of
bloody conspiracy if given a chance
there were many times where astred
thought she would leave him but stayed
because regardless of his Mead
consumption and maladjusted ways Emil
was the one man she had ever been happy
with she remained his wife for another
10 years until sickness took her now
completely alone Emil Schroeder was
practically a living ghost haunting the
home where his long since deceased
parents had raised him without ASD or
any relatives to help him run the Farm
Stand his personal funds dwindled until
he could barely afford to keep Bread on
his own table The Man became shrewd and
withdrawn but kicked his vices to the
curb in order to live on this was
particularly out of love for the wife he
had lost who he knew who would have
hated to see him suffer so he dreamed of
her often as well as Noah who is
perpetually a boy in the tales told by
his subconscious as Emil Grew Older
still he was sometimes confused and
misremembered himself and ased raising
Noah as their son before remembering the
truth of the matter and why the death of
one led to his association with the
other was during the winter months when
Emil Schroeder was the most active
handing out sweets to every child in the
village and giving sincere but solemn
warnings to their parents he would
Patrol the streets like a militia man
keeping an eye out for anything out of
place like that Snowman from his
childhood a memory that he kept all
these years despite so much changing
around him this brings us back to a 7
2-year-old Emil schroer standing on the
side of a river he watches and waits for
the arrival of something that he barely
can comprehend an embodiment of evil
that never strikes when expected if his
vigil could prevent even one crisis then
it would be all the worth it when all
was said and done all day Emil stood
there until one of the children from
town came and approached him old man
schroer said the boy are you cold Emil
turned and saw that the youth standing
behind him was no more than 7 years of
age age every time the familiar
tragedies happened in the hamlet there
was always a child younger than eight
Emil examined the face of the boy until
his mind willed the words from his weary
lips what is your name child said Emil
Frederick sir the boy replied Emil
smiled outwardly but within he couldn't
shake a sense of for booding he stealed
himself for the next question he had to
ask are your parents looking forward
through you Frederick nodded and told
the me that his parents wanted this to
be the best y ever ever so they made
sure to get a great U log and plenty of
delicious cow milk to drink has anything
strange been happening with the
preparations have you or your parents
seen things Emil asked Frederick paused
seemingly Unsure how to answer Emil
quickly changed the subject you know my
wife and I had the perfect recipe for
ginger cookies no U season is complete
without them perhaps your parents would
be interested in some this made Fredick
very excited and he agreed to take a
meal to his house house for a visit at
first Frederick's parents were concerned
about a visit from the lonely and
eccentric old man Schroeder but in the
spirit of the season they accepted his
company Emil made sure to thank them for
their Hospitality with gifts of ginger
cookies for the first time in several
years Emil schroer was not alone of
course this was not why he had come to
visit Frederick's family there were
strange sounds in this house none loud
or unusual enough to not be mistaken for
a creaky floorboard or an animal on the
roof but they were there Emil wondered
to himself if this would be the night
that he would understand what his life
had been building to he joined the
family for a warm meal by the fire and
as they drank glasses of milk friederick
asked to hear a Ule story with some
prodding Emil offered up a story from
the distant past it was one he had been
told as a child by his own parents the
story of a monster who only came once a
year when I tell you the tale I want you
to know know that it was passed down for
Generations in my family all the way
back to my Viking ancestor Vigo the
Berserker Frederick clapped his hands
and settled in to hear Emil's story
while his parents hoped the old man
wouldn't tell something too frightening
with that Emil began weaving the image
of an ancient and storied Viking long
housee he told it just like his parents
told him describing the many great and
powerful warriors that lived in that
Hall among them of course was was a
well-honed Berserker by the name of vgo
for several nights the Vikings called
out to Odin in Blissful reverence they
were so merry that the signs of strange
wickedness around the long house went
beneath their notice the wind howled the
roof creaked and the snow was rifted
with bizarre animalistic footsteps and
yet the Vikings partied on in complete
ignorance until the 12th night of fule
came and there was a fearsome knock at
the door now this banging came as quite
a surprise to Vikings as all the people
in the area had come to celebrate Ule in
the long house from the men and women to
the youngest children who could it be if
everyone was already inside especially
as the weather was cold and damp and the
ground was covered in several feet of
snow yet the knocking had come and it
persisted none but Vigo were so bold as
to answer the door as he had the wild
strength of the Berserker in his heart
as he undid the latch he called out into
the blizzard and said who is so very
late to join our marman we must offer
you a glass of mead he pulled open the
wooden door and through the crack he saw
a face it was unlike any man he had ever
seen before at first he thought he was
looking upon a frozen corpse bruised and
eaten Away by frostbite but then the
gnarled thing spoke ah the Mart has just
begun for I have
arrived in an instant the Torches inside
the long housee were blown out with a
howling gust of wind the door was forced
open and the creature entered it was
wire thin but vigorous in movement as a
stag with the strength of a bear with a
small blade in hand it descended upon
the Vikings slashing this way and that
the Warriors grabbed their Spears and
axes and tried to fa the creature but
its hide turned away their iron like it
was made out of the very Cliffs Of The
Sea it played with the Vikings and made
sport of snuffing out each of their
lives as the battle turned against them
they realized that there was no escape
nowhere to go but the cold raging storm
that claimed them as much as the
creature Vigo too was struck down like
everyone else but his Berserker trans
kept him clinging to this world long
enough to see the strange thing take a
young boy the only Survivor and stuff
him inside of a sack of cloth what are
you Vigo called out unsure if he was in
this world or the next the creature
smiled and replied as long as there are
holy days for thee I too shall
then the fell thing departed in the
morning vgo found himself still alive
but forever shaken ail book ended the
telling by saying that vgo lived to
marry and thus continue his line down to
ail himself or so The Story Goes by this
point friederick and his parents were
equally unnerved but Emil simply smiled
and made an offer he was waiting to make
for the whole evening I think I will
return your hospitality now how about
tomorrow night you all stay at my family
home home and we will tell a happier
story as Emil said this his eyes were
fixated on the window out there in the
dark was a shape not unlike a snowman a
shape that had chosen its next Target
but perhaps would need to reconsider for
the first time in almost a hundred years
Marry youu You Old Devil all we hope is
that you will not see what the Blood Red
Sky kishar saw as he ran through the
streets all around him were the sounds
of violence women screaming as their
babies were stolen from their arms axes
swung towards men who were just trying
to protect their families kar's sandals
fell apart as he ran the leather falling
from his feet as the hard Stones drew
blood all around him was red the blood
from his feet the burning buildings and
of course the cursed sky above his head
Kar ran out through the gates of the
city and in Into the Wilderness looking
back over his shoulder he saw smoke
engulfing the skies above it all stood
the Tower of Babel a shadow hidden in
Smoke Beneath The Blood Red Sky what had
once been a source of Refuge hope and
wisdom for kishar now looked like the
arrival of Hell on Earth the Persian
army swarmed around the city like ants
blowing holes in the city walls and
torching house after house arrows flew
with with total abandon he wasn't sure
if they were even being fired at anyone
in particular all night he had been
waiting for one of them to Lodge itself
between his shoulder blades but somehow
he had survived Kar ran through the
desert until his legs gave out on him he
lay on his back staring up at the night
sky no longer was it just red but purple
and blacks and blues and colors he'd
never even seen before things his eyes
didn't quite understand as much as he
had been afraid of the Persian army a
new fear crept into his stomach one
deeper and more Primal it wasn't just
the Persian army who were bringing
judgment to his people it was God
himself fear pushing him to keep going
the armies would find him within a day
if he stopped here he needed to hide to
find somewhere safe that he could spend
the night on the horizon was a rocky
outcrop there must be a cave in there
somewhere there had to be an hour later
kesar stumbled through the Rocks leaving
bloody Footprints with every step his
mouth was horse and dry his legs burned
and wobbled barely capable of supporting
his weight anymore Stop The Voice echoed
between the cliffs becoming so loud that
kishar believed he truly found God but
it was a man or rather a group of men
dressed in black and white robes that
were standing at the entrance to a cave
they were well-dressed
looked well fed and clean perhaps they
could help him unable to speak he mimed
desperately for water as he collapsed on
the ground at their feet but all that he
was met with was a jab from one of their
staffs wincing kishar rolled onto his
back and whispered his pleas up at them
all that the man told him was that he
was to go far far away from this place
and forget he had ever seen it kesar
tried to explain that the Persian army
had invaded Babylon had fallen and that
it was all over but the man just carried
on Staring at him seemingly unfaced by
what he told them one of them looked up
at the sky at the dark swirling colors
and gestured to the others come we must
return inside the sky is worse than I
feared Driven Crazy by desperation
kashar pushed himself to his feet barged
his way past the men and sprinted into
the cave his foot caught a rock and he
went tumbling rolling down down down
along a slope that led deep into the
Earth behind him he could hear the men
shouting and chasing all he needed was a
drink he would take their water endure
their beating and be on his way but he
looked up his blood ran cold he was not
alone in this cave there suspended in
front of him was a kind of ball it was
slightly larger than he was and hung in
the air without anything to support it
his eyes could not make sense of what
they were seeing the all shimmered like
shallow water being agitated by
someone's hand it was black and white
the colors fighting against each other
like droplets of rain that were thrown
around by the wind but at the same time
it wasn't those things he could see
through it slightly he could see the
other wall of the cave kishar stood up
and slowly crept around the side of the
ball not even noticing the voices of the
men crying louder in his ears looking
through it was though the world was bent
out of shape flickering and jutting with
energy he reached out a curious hand
what will it feel like to touch the
thing to feel a miracle with his hand
his trembling fingers crept closer and
closer to the edge of the orb he took a
breath and plunged his arm inside
immediately pain like he had never
experienced shot through his body and
that was when he saw it on the other
side of the orb standing with its back
pressed against the wall of the cave was
something so horrific that the air left
his lungs thrashing and screaming by the
time the men reached the cave Kar had
collapsed on the floor he died soon
after as two of the men went about
carrying his body back out of the cave
another sat quietly in the corner with
the Epic of gilgames open on his lap
reading in a calm voice and watching as
over in the corner of the room the orb
gradually shrunk in size if at any point
the sky begins to change color without
any stimuli or obvious explanation as to
why it's happening all Foundation
members are immediately to go into alert
level 7 all Personnel stationed at sites
05 and 06 to go into alert level 8 and
immediately began to prepare new methods
for containing SCP
001 site 5 has been constructed around
Point Alpha the place where all of this
begins Point Alpha is believed to have
existed for thousands of years the
earliest known records of its existence
come from the Babylonian Empire a number
of manuscripts make reference to the
existence of this cave and a group of
sages known as the order of white and
black it was their duty to patrol the
cave and protected from anyone
discovering what was hidden inside at
the fall of the Babylonian Empire as the
aramed Persians invaded this order was
replaced by a group of Zer roian monks
of whom there are few written records
much of their history was passed down
orally the most substantial account that
the foundation has to date comes from
the ancient Greek philosopher Zer who
made an expedition into the ainan Empire
and found Point Alpha unlike most who
came before him the monks walked him
Zera into the cave with open arms he had
spent years traveling deepening his
understanding of philosophy and culture
he was a great lover of literature and
early on in his travels he acquired so
many manuscripts he had been forced to
purchase a camel just so that he could
take them all with him traveling from
town to town he had collected story
after Story myth after myth from all the
local peoples with the goal of finding
what it was that unified Humanity across
cultures races and religions it was
because of his camel that the monks were
so happy to see him they rushed him
inside and almost immediately began to
unpack his thing things and lay them out
in a special chamber that they had dug
into the cave walls all night they
prepared extravagant food for him
slaughtering a goat and preparing it
over the open flames in celebration it
was only once he was well rested they
introduced him to what was housed deeper
in the cave Zera had the same fearful
reaction that kishar had centuries
before only he had the common sense not
to put his hand into the ball but the
Stillness of the moment around him
helped to put him at ease they calmly
explained to him that it was his turn to
read a story and that he may pick any
Tales he liked from his collection of
manuscripts they beckoned him over to a
cushion on one side of the cave where he
knelt and began to read as he did so he
saw the creature inside the orb for the
first time it skirted around the
opposite wall of the cave and peered at
him with a look something like curiosity
the the creature wasn't a human that
much was apparent it was emaciated like
many of the children that he had seen on
his travels but unlike them it was
enormous its hunch figure seemed to fill
up the cave and in another way seemed to
be Beyond The Cave somehow his eyes
couldn't quite make sense of what they
were seeing but as he read the creature
seemed to find contentment it was very
still and very focused on his words he
wondered if it could even understand
what he was saying so he paused and
decided to ask it that question almost
immediately the creature began to thrash
its way and that either Agony or rage
distorted its face Zera tried to calm it
down to talk gently to it to reassure
that everything was okay but nothing
made a difference the sphere itself
started to pulse and grow larger
Rippling and shaking with energy the
monks yelled at him to continue reading
and he did so no sooner had he read the
next sentence than the creature creatur
seemed to calm and the sphere began to
shrink again how interesting all told
zero spent 7 months living in the cave
with the monks he exhausted all of the
literature that he had brought with him
while making sure to write detailed
notes every evening about what he had
witnessed and what he had learned
firstly it seemed as if the creature did
understand him because when he read
stories that were of higher quality with
more interesting characters and greater
Stakes it seemed to be calmer and more
interested in what he had to say the
weaker stories that he had picked up
local folklore and cautionary tales had
less of an effect and the creatures
seemed closer to agitation as he read
them on a number of occasions he had
been forced to abandon the story early
in favor of a better one as the creature
on the other side of the orb seemed to
run out of patience for what he was
saying yet it would not speak back to
him he heard no voice and saw no
attempts from this creature to Comm
communicate with him in any way it did
not seem to build any kind of emotional
connection with him it did not matter
whether he was reading or one of the
monks was all the creature seemed to
care about was the quality of what was
being read to it apparently that was
what all the monks cared about as well
as soon as Zur had run out of
manuscripts to read to the creature he
was escorted out of the cave and sent on
his way without so much as a loaf of
bread following the conquest of
Alexander the Great po Alpha was once
again claimed by a different
civilization en raptured by the writings
of Zera Alexander had made a specific
point to conquer this region he
established his own order known as the
Kronos guard to whom he gave a selection
of the finest Greek ethics to read
inside the cave it was their belief that
they had found Kronos and were punishing
him by reading these Tales the group
stood throughout the rise of the sasanid
empire and even the formation of the
rashan Calif F before eventually being
replaced by an Islamic equivalent named
the society for the containment of the
Babel demon presently po Alpha is under
the control of the SCP Foundation the
cushion and the monk in the corner have
been replaced by a speaker about 5 m
away from the anomaly herein referred to
as SCP 00 1-1 whatever it is that is
living inside or on the other side of
the sphere is referred to as SCP 00 1-2
the speaker that reads into it is run
from a series of backup generators so
that at no point will there be a break
in the flow of literature the speaker is
connected directly to site 06 and the
scip net database due to the inherent
danger of close proximity to SCP
0011 no Personnel are authorized to
visit Point Alpha anymore anything that
comes into physical contact with SCP 001
D2 is immediately turned into Argon gas
it is is the foundation's goal through
Reading literature to keep SCP 0012
entertained at all times if at any point
the literature stops or SCP 0000 1-2 is
not satisfied by the quality of what is
being read to it
scp1 will occur this refers to the event
where SCP 00 1-1 starts to expand and
the sky spontaneously changes color
initially turning blood red if not
rapidly controlled this soon constitutes
a reality breakdown event natural
disasters begin to happen all throughout
the world and in various places reality
itself starts to fall apart it goes
without saying this is not ideal in
order for Humanity to survive and
perhaps the universe itself to continue
it is of utmost importance that SCP 00
1-2 receives constant high quality
Entertainment Security classification of
this SCP was temporarily lowered so that
all all level two Personnel would have
access to the file and the ability to
suggest Solutions one of the first
suggestions that was raised was the idea
of using artificial intelligence to
constantly generate story content to be
read over the speaker this suggestion
was approved and quickly put into
practice but almost immediately SCP 00
1-2 began to thrash violently and SCP
001 D1 rapidly expanded this led
directly to a currently redacted natural
disaster on the other side of the world
in the mid 2000s another suggestion was
that the foundation employ a team of the
world's best authors and writers to
continually pen stories to satisfy the
creature the suggestion was denied as
historical documentation has proven time
and time again that SCP 0012 does not
respond well to literature that has been
written specifically for it the stories
must be organic and serve a greater
purpose a recent Containment Breach
pushed the foundation to start
experimenting with with methods that
they had previously denied the most
important of these was the reading of a
main lless document from the SCP
Foundation itself to the creature
previously the suggestion had been shut
down as it would constitute an
information leak but desperation led the
foundation to try reading one of the
accounts of a different SCP to it this
was an overwhelming success the SCP
document was able to be read over 14
times before SCP 00 1-2 got bored of
hearing it off the back of this trial
the foundation approved the
declassification of a number of SCP main
lless documents to be read to SCP
0012 at first there were only 999 scps
that could be read to it but as the
foundation crept towards running out of
numbers they decided to expand Beyond
999 scps up to
7,999 as of right now this is where the
total sits but the foundation may be
forc in the future to expand even beyond
that number most interestingly of all
the foundation seems to have stumbled
upon a more permanent solution the
creation as a file describing SCP 001
itself perhaps even in the form of an
animated video SCP 00 1-2 seems to
demonstrate a level of enjoyment for
stories that mention itself but the
added layer suggested by the foundation
member was that this animated video
could be recursive like the images you
see zooming closer and closer and closer
without ever really stopping or getting
any closer to a conclusion a video that
could be cyclical and start itself again
so that the story would never cease
after all all we hope is that you will
never see the Blood Red Sky kishar saw
as he ran through the streets all around
him were the sounds of violence women
screaming as their babies were stolen
from their arms axes swung towards men
who were just trying to protect their
families Kar sandals fell apart as he
ran the leather falling from his feet as
the hard Stones drew blood all around
him was red Russell's Back was pressed
against the wall his shuttering hands
gripping the fire ax the low emergency
lighting filling the corridor indicated
the lockdown was still in effect
although that was simultaneously a
blessing and a curse sure it meant that
thing couldn't get out hopefully but it
also meant that Russell was stuck in the
wing of the facility with it he had no
idea if anyone else was left he hadn't
seen what it happened to Carpenter maybe
it got him or perhaps he had managed to
give it the slip at the last second
there was no way of knowing for sure it
had all started so simply so innocently
and with such Noble intentions if he had
known it would lead to all this madness
Russell would have never put his name
down on the request form the CP
Foundation had been working on a way to
neutralize or cure SCP 610 for what felt
like forever to one team of scientists
the infamously so-called flesh that
hates was a fascinating organism it was
a highly contagious saric skin disease
isolated entirely within a small area of
Siberia that on its own wasn't enough to
Peak the interest of the research team
led by Dr Carpenter including his
handpicked star researchers Russell and
David along with their assistant clenon
and Dr Boton an expert on infectious
diseases who had recently joined their
efforts to provide his specialist
knowledge what did Captivate all of them
however was what SCP 610 did when it
infected a human being the disease would
trigger aggressive and uncontrollable
mutations within its infected and could
virtually rewrite their entire
physiology in a heartbeat the flesh that
hates was capable of transforming a
person's body into a horrifying fleshy
mass of Limbs and matter that barely
resemble the human being anymore and in
addition the infected individuals would
retain some level of awareness attacking
any uninfected person with extreme
hostility there had long been chatter
amongst some other research teams
studying SCP 610 about devising a way to
weaponize the disease if they could
somehow create a variant that didn't
turn people into monsters or at least
caused the fleshy Abominations to die
shortly after mutation then the
foundation or another interested party
could deploy the flesh that hates as a
biological weapon Dr Carpenter had long
uphor the idea instead searching for a
way to completely reverse the effects of
an SCP 610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
home researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried treating SCP 610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr botton's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get SCP 049 to take a look at the
infected patient Clinton suggested oh
might work Carpenter mused although even
if he cills someone he might also kill
them yeah has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem uh there's
always
682 David said dryly have the reptile
eat up all the SCP 610 infectees and
voila problem solved oh real helpful
David researcher Russell retorted and
what are we going to do when SCP 682
adapts to the flesh you really want an
infected Immortal lizard on the loose
Gentlemen please Dr botton spoke up
we're forgetting one obvious option I
propose we submit a joint formal request
to use SCP 914 for this experiment
unanimously the group all agreed that
this was the best course of action SCP
914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two booths marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
CP 914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in SCP 9914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks a rule that the team's
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize SCP 914 before it was submitted
to the foundation hups within hours the
request was denied but the team was
determined that SCP 914 could be the key
to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with SCP 610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision urging
the hups to reconsider he argued that
this flouting of the no organic matter
rule was necessary to potentially rid
the world of the flesh that hates after
a few days of consideration the request
was finally fatefully granted the team
went to work immediately requisitioning
two test subjects both of which had
suffered SCP 610 in infections and were
horribly mutated the pair of them were
deemed a potential Hazard to every
member of foundation staff on site and
as a result the entire wing of the
facility where the Clockworks was housed
had to be evacuated for safety dressed
in biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of SCP 9914 this
was the test run they wanted to see if
the Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with CP 610 at all
plus they needed a fail safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked clenon to set the Clockworks too
rough and with a click and were of its
numerous gears and Gyros SCP 9914 came
to life instantly the infected test
subject was completely obliterated the
setting had reduced it to atoms
disintegrating it on such a microscopic
level that there was nothing left in the
output chamber the second infected
creature seemed to bristle with anger
but didn't attack or become aggressive
as it too was proded towards the
Clockworks next perhaps out of fear that
their Theory might be wrong the team
agreed to set SCP 914 to its one:1
setting sure enough the machine
recreated another instance of a specimen
infected with the flesh that hates
replacing the previous one we all know
we're stalling researcher David piped up
let's do what we came here for set the
Clockworks to course nervously receiving
a nod from Dr Carpenter clenon stepped
forward to switch the dial on SCP 914 to
the course setting this was the primary
reason the team had all agreed to use
the machine on a flesh specimen this
setting could disassemble any item
placed in the input Booth separating it
into its base components Boton had
suggested the use of SCP 914 based on
the theory that if it worked correctly
the Clockworks could extract the flesh
that hates from its infected host
rendering them free of the disease the
machine made a colossal amount of noise
as clenon hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the dial hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement setting 914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled at clenon before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by SC SCP 610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a pair
of foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became became a
part of it the guards arms and legs
forming additional limbs as their forms
were reconstituted and repurposed as
part of a monster that was now crawling
on its six legs towards the research
team in a blind panic the group
scrambled for the entrance the head of
the infected man splitting open down the
middle opening up into a wide snapping
pair of Jaws panting hard as he ran his
breath fogging up the clear face plate
of The Biohazard suit Russell ran
through the door hearing someone close
behind he stopped for a moment looking
back to see the creature on the other
side of the door starting to spill
through the door frame like a liquid
running faster around a corner Russell
came to another halt in the common area
a third security guard following just
before a thick Steel security door came
slamming down sealing the creature on
the other side the other door didn't
hold it what good is that going to do
researcher David yelled more to the
point Dr Carpenter said turning and
marching towards clenon he launched a
furious punch at the assistant knocking
him to the floor why did you set 9914 to
very fine clenon the enraged doctor
shouted you're the one who Unleashed
that Abomination you maniac what Clinton
replied fearfully trembling I I didn't I
swear I didn't it said course I'm sure
of it you expect us to believe that was
a mistake gentlemen we need to focus on
the situation at hand the security
officer interjected regardless of who's
responsible we need to inform the
foundation hups there's an emergency
lock down Russell replied it would have
triggered the moment the SCP 610
specimen got free you've trapped us with
a monster clenon doct Carpenter spat
hold on researcher David spoke up wasn't
it botton's idea to use 9914 in the
first place the common area fell silent
as everyone turned to look at Dr Boton
did you plan for this doc David pushed
Boton chuckled need I remind you my
friends that we all agreed to use the
Clockworks did we not all of our names
are on the request he answered besides
accusing me David that's rather Rich
coming from you what's that supposed to
mean the researcher fired back beckoning
his finger Boton encouraged the rest of
the team to follow him across the common
area to where a row of lockers stood
each door bearing one of their names he
gestured to the one labeled David go on
Boton added shooting him a dirty look
David barged past the disease expert and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leatherbound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying SCP 610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasm
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in texts revered by saric
Cults who worship death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarcus carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
researcher David protested I I've never
seen that before it was in your locker
the doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh for your Twisted death
worshipping religion it certainly seems
that way Boton interjected after all
research a David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even you
David pointed at the doctor you planted
this in my locker you're here a sarcast
clenon repeated in a nervous stammer you
made me turn the dial to very fine you
made that thing of fear you made me your
accomplice anger tears streamed down his
face Clinton's hand reached for the
security officer's gun and went to draw
it planning to shoot David on the spot
but as he went to pull the weapon from
the guard's holster it wouldn't budge it
was then that assistant clenon stared in
horror at his hand his fingers had fused
to the guard's leg the officer gave a
twisted grin as his torso burst open
tendrils of Flesh latching on to clenon
and assimilating him just like it had
done before the flesh creature broke
down on its victim's body making it a
new part of itself a grotesque mass of
Limbs and bloody matter littered with
the discarded faces of those it had
infected the research team looked at it
terrified their stomachs turning
disgusted at the growing growling
abomination of bodies fused to one
another oh you're beautiful Russell
Heard a Voice whisper behind him he
turned to see Boton looking at the SCP
610 creature and smiling researcher
David was the closest and the creature
lunched at him pulling his leg out from
under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching skin tearing and
Bones snapping as he became part of it a
new set of Limbs added to the monster Dr
Carpenter went to try and pull him free
but it was already too late and he
stepped back knowing that if he touched
it he would be infected too the sound of
running caught Russell's attention and
he spotted botton making a break for it
grabbing Dr Carpenter by the sleeve the
researcher pulled him in the same
direction partly running away from the
flesh as it assimilated David and partly
chasing the saric savitur the pair of
them quickly caught up to Boton leaning
over himself and panting breathlessly
thank God you two made it he wheezed
after the run I can't believe David
could do this to unleash this nightmare
Upon Us Russell thought to snap at him
to scream how dare he keep lying but
boton's back was to him now he'd never
get a better chance there was a cabinet
on the Corridor wall containing a fire
axe for emergencies as carefully and
quietly as he could Russell fished the
axe out of its case while spoton and
carpenter were looking away we should
get the foundation to lift the lock down
Boton was saying they need to let us out
and
then he let out a blood curdling scream
mids sentence as the ax blade wounded
him Russell pulled it back standing over
the doctor as he fell to the floor in
agony Russell have you lost your mind
Carpenter exclaimed no doctor he's the
cultist I have no no idea how he tricked
clenon but that flesh creature exists
because of him the researcher answered
from the floor unable to move thanks to
his injury Dr botton began to laugh it
took me years to infiltrate the
foundation so much time waiting to gain
access to that blessed flesh he glutted
and now you've helped me to refine it to
create its ultimate form you want to
kill me go ahead Russell oh my life
doesn't matter for once that creature is
free it will bring about a new age of
Flesh and Grand Caris iron will reward
me for the role I played in unleashing
it David was right Carpenter realized
Buton you you planted that book on him
to throw us off doctor we need to think
of something researcher Russell
interjected act still in hand nobody
knows more about the flesh that hates
than us there must be a way to kill that
thing otherwise if it gets out of this
lockdown it could spread to everyone in
the foundation what about fire that's
been effective against 610 infectees
before right yes yes but the doctor
desperately tried to think this new
being we've created he created Russell
argued looking at the grimacing wounded
Boton we cannot deny the role we've all
played in this researcher Carpenter
argued and we have no idea if it
possesses the same weaknesses as the
flesh before its refinement but we have
to try sir the researcher protested of
course I agree the sickening sound of a
slithering slick Mass was rapidly
approaching still laying on the floor in
pain Dr Boton had been dragged to the
middle of a junction with Carpenter and
Russell hiding around either Corner
suddenly botton started hollering as the
flesh came into view practically calling
it to him oh look at you he exclaimed
you're better than I could have ever
hoped for looking down at him with the
faces it had collected the creature
stabed one of its disgusting appendages
through botton drawing its body into its
growing form I am honored to give my
life so that the age of Flesh May begin
the doctor said we weakly through the
pain as he was infected from around the
corner Carpenter had taken the saric
text and set its pages on fire with a
cigarette lighter turning to the
creature he hurled the mass of burning
paper at it hoping it would be enough
fire to spread to the flesh while it was
assimilating Boton who they had left
there as bait the fiery book collided
with the monstrosity as Russell peaked
around the corner he saw the flesh
retreating from the Flames boton's body
now added to it for a moment it seemed
like the creature was afraid of the fire
but slowly it drew nearer and nearer to
the book with ease it stamped down the
Flames with boton's leg dowsing the fire
and suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the axe in his hands Russell
went to charge of the creature only to
feel something push him back Dr
Carpenter had stopped him run he yelled
instantly Russell turned and raced down
the corridor the sound of fleshy
tentacles whipping through the air he
dared not look back just in case the
monster was right behind him eventually
he reached another corner and slammed
his back against it hands shut
shuttering as he held on to the fire axe
he had no idea what had happened to
Carpenter maybe it got him or perhaps he
had managed to give it the slip at the
last second Russell came a hush voice
from around the corner one the
researcher recognized he turned to see
Dr Carpenter approaching him sneaking
like he was trying to avoid being heard
I think I managed to give it the slip
the doctor whispered for a second
Russell backed up his hands tightening
around the ax handle this might have
looked like Dr Carpenter but was it are
you really you doctor he asked of course
I am Carpenter replied you don't think
that I'm not that monstrosity Russell
raised the axe defensively only to
notice the sadness in the doctor's face
unable to bring himself to swing even to
find out the researcher lowered his
weapon Carpenter looked grateful come on
let's get them to lift this lock down he
said I'm sure an MTF can step in and
take care of our mistake as the pair of
them cautiously made their way towards
one of the locked doors Dr Carpenter
reached out a hand to place it on
Russell's shoulder Fearless Relentless
and one of the most utterly brutal
Warriors to ever walk the face of the
Earth with a body counts somewhere in
the high hundred thousands if not well
into multiple Millions given just how
long he's been around for many of you
will already be well aware of SCP 076-2
also known as Abel on the surface he's a
man of Middle Eastern descent covered in
tattoos of occultt symbols and demonic
faces usually contained within a stone
Cube designated as CP
0761 Abel will often emerge in a
homicidal State killing anyone and
anything directly around him how well by
any means available to him but primarily
by pulling a wide array of bladed
weapons seemingly out of thin air this
is thanks to a tiny pocket Dimension
that only he can reach into which is
also always stalked with an assortment
of deadly implements for his latest
murder spree as of being highly combat
proficient and always armed didn't make
him enough of an imposing threat SCP
076-2 also possesses a near superhuman
resistance to damage making him
incredibly difficult to take down and
even if someone is able to eventually
neutralize him AEL will also come back
resurrecting inside SCP
0761 to fight another day what you may
not know is for a Time AEL actually
worked alongside the SCP Foundation
although nowadays they prefer to keep
him locked away in a secure containment
facility underwater which they will
flood with seawater if he ever escapes
but Abel was once appointed the leader
of his own mobile task force Omega 7
referred to under the code name of
Pandora's Box you see the foundation
realized that SCP 076-2 held an
especially high regard for those who
proved well able to best him in combat
and it was the this strange code of
honor that Abel held that the foundation
hoped to exploit with the creation of
Pandora's Box comprised of MTF
operatives that had earned Abel's
respect most by previously beating him
in a fair fight or as Fair as a fight
with a man who can summon swords through
a tear in the fabric of reality can be
these agents would support Abel during
missions in the field during which the
SCP Foundation were able to deploy the
anomalous warrior in various tactical
engagements however this didn't last
long eventually Abel grew tired of
carrying out the orders of the
foundation The Immortal Warrior craved a
challenge Breaking Free of containment
and turning on the foundation resulting
in AEL being neutralized by an on-site
nuclear weapon this marked the end of
the fragile alliance between SCP 076-2
and the SCP Foundation leaving the
existence of Omega 7 a classified secret
and one of the organization's most
embarrassing missteps well well but what
if that hadn't happened what if out
there in the infinite Multiverse there
was a world where Abel had been allowed
to remain a part of Omega 7 and the
mobile task force was never disbanded
well you're about to find out in our
world Able's dissatisfaction with being
a member of Pandora's Box first became
apparent when he began putting the rest
of his unit through live fire exercises
brutalizing his men despite these
exercises being intended as for training
purposes only but in this world the
injuries and even casualties AEL
inflicted on the rest of Omega 7 were
met with a much different response the
05 Council of this alternate version of
the SCP Foundation viewed ael's
outbursts during training as acceptable
losses every time he would injure one of
Omega 7 the council would demand that
Replacements be on hand to become part
of the task force drawn from the ranks
of the other mtfs at their disposal
after all Abel was a valuable asset said
for carrying out the foundation's Dirty
Work by continually replenishing his
team with reserves from their seemingly
inexhaustible supply of other MTF agents
the 05 Council of this world were able
to keep SCP 076-2 firmly under their
employ however it is also important to
note that Abel's patience for these new
recruits was far more limited than the
original Omega 7s those men had all been
handpicked by Abel personally and
appointed to the project given that he
had some modum of respect for them as
combatants whereas all of their
Replacements were plucked at random from
the foundation's other mtfs as a result
SCP 076-2 would carelessly kill or wound
more and more of these reserves during
combat missions hardly distinguishing
between friend and foe but despite this
the 05 Council refused to discontinue
the Omega 7 project viewing these as
acceptable losses and letting the
success rate of ael's missions justif
ified the depletion of their other
mobile task forces under ael's
leadership and the command of the 05
Council Omega 7 would become the
foundation's primary rapid response unit
and the most deployed task force for
Dangerous field operations and working
for the foundation meant that every
field mission was a highly dangerous one
such was the case during one Containment
Breach where SCP 682 managed to get free
of a tacid tank a rampaging infinitely
adaptable hard to destroy reptile on the
loose slaughtering all in its path was
bad enough but the 05 Council had
received Intel that there was something
more behind this breakout than it first
seemed and so Abel and the rest of his
latest Omega 7 team were sent in to
pacify SCP 682 bursting into the
facility eager to once again be freed
from containment and the monotonous
underwhelming experience of training
Abel flew into combat drawing black
swords from his personal Armory he began
to to tear through everything and
everyone in his path unfortunately for
the foundation Personnel on site this
also meant they were subject to Abel's
Relentless wrath as if running away from
SCP 682 wasn't bad enough fleeing
research staff were quickly met with the
swing of SCP 076-2 weapons and removed
from the premises in a brutal fashion
still this meant little to Abel and even
less to the 05 Council as far as they
were concerned even their own staff were
just collateral damage more acceptable
losses justified by ael's Perfect record
for successful high-risk High reward
field missions however that perfect
record was about to be tarnished for
good you see this Containment Breach
wasn't your average SCP 682 escape
attempt it was instead a situation that
had been meticulously planned and
carried out for one purpose this breach
was intended specifically to draw AEL
out since he had become the SCP
foundation's primary weapon and response
to danger in the field a particularly
devious third party had begun to take
note the chaos Insurgency a splinter
faction that began its life as an off
thee books Black Ops unit for the
foundation themselves had been
monitoring Abel's deployment by the 05
Council in this universe their origin
was the same as in ours and the
Insurgency took a certain disdain to
seeing an anomalous individual carrying
out the kind of operations their group
had been formed to undertake for the
foundation Additionally the use of SCP
076-2 as a personal attack dog by the 05
council is hypocricy the Insurgency
believed in the practical application of
anomalies rather than locking them up
and keeping them contained and it was
for this belief that they had been
vilified by the foundation and yet here
was the same organization sending Abel
on missions with no care for the harm he
caused and so as a result the cast
Insurgency had conducted an operation to
break into the foundation free SCP 682
and send the hardto destroy reptile on a
rampage also they could take their shot
at able being ambushed by a group of C
Insurgency operatives on his way to
engage SCP 682 Abel was admittedly
caught by surprise but by now his combat
prowess was second to almost nobody else
in the world the insurgents dog piled on
ail unleashing every ounce of Firepower
they had brought to bear on the immortal
Warrior the ensuing firefight destroyed
an entire wing of the foundation
facilities explosive weapons being
detonated in the hopes that the
Insurgency could subdue AEL all the
while SCP 076-2 Shrugged off the
oncoming damage catching rockets that
were launched at him and throwing them
back in the direction of the chaos
insurgents it was a bloodbath nearly the
entire Omega 7 team that had accompanied
Abel and provided him with fire support
were lying to dead the same could also
be said for the Insurgency forces too
though with each of them being gradually
felled by the warriors's many weapons
but by this point Abel was approaching
exhaustion and there was still one more
enemy left standing it had been
unfurling destruction all on its own
angrily devouring the few Foundation
Personnel that were left and now the
scaly form of SCP 682 came lumbering
around the corner the battle was brutal
in this universe AEL and the hard to
destroy reptile had never crossed paths
before but SCP 682 could smell the
difference in Abel's physiology his
innate ability to resist damage and
resurrect time and time again the
creature already held the stain for
anything and everything living and so
presented with a man who technically
couldn't stop living SCP 682 entered an
Unstoppable rage State taking the
exhausted able down with ease but losing
in a grudge match against SCP 682 wasn't
quite as bad as things were about to get
for AEL Reviving inside of his Stone
sarcophagus the ancient warrior was
confused the foundation were letting him
out it had been a long time years even
since he had last died even temporarily
over the course of all of his Omega 7
missions he hadn't needed to reappear
back inside SCP 0761 for quite a
considerable while and now that he had a
very large seed of Doubt had been sown
the 05 Council were Furious just as
angry at SCP 076-2 apparent failure as
able was the perfect operational track
record of their top anomalous asset was
now tarnished the question started to
spread through the council members if
their sword Wheeling virtually
invulnerable secret weapon wasn't as
effective as they had previously thought
then what was the use of continuing to
deploy able and so began a debate within
the 05 Council upon what was to be the
fate of SCP 076-2 too in this universe
he had served the foundation well but a
weapon that is only effective even 90%
of the time still leaves a margin of
error it was that risk that potential
for error knowing that AEL wouldn't
always succeed in his missions that
caused the 05 Council to reconsider his
applications as a field operative there
were some in the council who argued that
this was a highly specific isolated
incident the chaos Insurgency had
specifically engineered the SCP 680 to
escape as a way to draw Abel out after
all just because he failed this time did
not indicate a pattern of failure but
this argument was eventually shot down
especially when the foundation's Ethics
Committee decided to throw in their two
cents they demanded able status as a
Field Agent B revoked and levied for the
immediate disbanding for the Omega 7
project pulling replacements for that
task force from other mtfs at the
foundation had left them with a
significantly depleted reserve of troops
and then came the AR argument about just
how acceptable the losses were when AEL
was let loose a decision was ultimately
made to for at least the moment resend
SCP 076-2 field operative Privileges and
suspend any further development of or
recruitment into Omega 7 however there
was one crucial factor that nobody on
the council had taken into consideration
when they made their verdict and that
was how badly AEL would react to the
news as you may have already predicted
did Abel was Furious to hear he would be
held in containment until further notice
his anger stemmed not from his defeat at
the jaws of SCP 682 but at how quick the
foundation seemingly was to question his
combat prowess he lost one battle out of
hundreds thousands even and all of a
sudden the 05 Council were going to lock
him away all because of one defeat you
dare Abel bellowed when he was given the
news I Am The Greatest Warrior on this
planet and have been made a part W by
your foundation I give you my strength
my skill and the moment I falter you
turn your back on me you dare you dare I
will show you what real power looks like
overcome with rage it didn't take long
for able to force his way out of
containment he'd been active as a field
agent within the foundation for so long
now that he had long since figured out a
way to escape his underwater prison
before the emergency containment
measures had a chance to stop him as he
broke free he made sure to take down
plenty of security staff along the way
and to make matters worse he didn't stop
there before long Abel was on a war path
against the SCP Foundation every few
days reports would come in of a massacre
at a foundation facility security
footage recovered from the wreckage
after each incident would show Abel
arriving primed for battle a sword in
each Hand by the time he left after his
brutal remorseless attack he'd be
drenched in the blood of the entire
site's Personnel the foundation station
had little in its once huge Arsenal to
fight back with given the number of MTF
agents reassigned to Omega 7 their
forces were far more limited if not
almost depleted they dispatched
attachments to clean up the wake of
Able's destruction but not one Squad
sent after the anomalous Warrior came
back alive part of the problem was the
foundation couldn't predict where AEL
would show up next or which of their
sights he knew about and was planning to
hit from their perspective his attacks
were spontaneous
the result of Rage at the foundation but
without any premeditated plan in mind
and that was exactly what Abel wanted
them to think by seeming to attack at
random he was therefore able to cover
the true intention behind each
engagement he was looking for something
during his considerable time leading
Omega 7 he had heard about a machine
that could improve anything placed
inside of it SCP 914 better known as the
Clockworks and before long able found
what he was looking for by the time the
foundation realized what the Unstoppable
Warrior's plan was it was already too
late Abel was storming into the facility
that housed SCP 914 with no intention of
leaving until he' used it the foundation
had banned testing of biological matter
within the Clockworks but Abel wasn't
beholden to their rules anymore in fact
he barely was when he'd worked with them
before cutting down guards and
researchers survivors fleeing in Terror
able stepped up towards the massive
gears and cogs the Clockwork components
that made up SCP 914 he wasted no time
setting the machine to very fine with
this setting the Clockworks would take
whatever was in the input booth and
improve it usually by giving it
anomalous Properties or in the case of
Abel by giving him further anomalous
properties stepping inside the were of
Machinery drowned out the emergency
alarms as able reached his goal to
become the ultimate Warrior the
embodiment of the very concept itself
racing to the scene a chopper cleared
the smoke as it approached under an
emergency executive order from the 05
Council the few surviving remnants of
the foundation's mobile task forces had
been combined into a singular Strike
Team there were not many left
considering how many others from their
units had been previously siphoned into
Omega 7 only to dieas collateral damage
in the team's missions with able
remember SCP 076 2 is a priority Target
the field commander barked while the MTF
Strike Team held their guns nervously
aboard the aircraft primary objective is
to neutralize him by any means reports
indicate that he may be trying to access
SCP 914 so be advised An Almighty
explosion boomed through the Airborne
vehicle engulfing the cockpit in Flames
mayday mayday mayday Chopper one has
been hit we're going down the commander
radioed to Foundation command everyone
braak yourselves for impact the
helicopter spiraled out of the air
crashing to the ground in a Twisted hunk
of metal the surviving members of the
Strike Team scrambled out of the
wreckage hauling the more badly wounded
out of the ruined aircraft contact
someone yelled in horror enemy contact
behind us the remaining Foundation foot
soldiers turned and Drew their weapons
opening fire on something suspended a
few feet in the air above them a hail of
gunfire rang out as the team opened fire
the second they saw who it was it was
AEL and he was flying
floating above them his hair whipped in
the wind the oncoming storm of bullets
seemed to Ricochet off his skin in
actuality they weren't even hitting him
melting away before they could make
contact they might as well have been
firing peashooters for how little effect
their guns had the barrage only stopped
when one of the Strike Team launched a
short-range rocket at the newly refined
Warrior it detonated but when the smoke
from the blast cleared able was still
hovering in the air without so much as a
scratch my turn he announced bounced
reaching into his pocket di mention Abel
pulled something out not a weapon not
yet instead it was a formless dark
shadowy mass that moved like liquid
metal reacting to the movement of his
hand as he drew the substance out it
reformed seemingly at ael's command and
it wasn't just swords he could create
now drawing on his experiences from his
Omega 7 missions any weapon that AEL had
previously seen or could think of he now
had at his disposal the Strike Team
looked up in horror as a veritable swarm
of black non-reflective constructs
hovered in the air on either side of
Abel each one in the shape of a rocket
flinging both arms towards the
foundation troops AEL sent his New
Creations raining down on them the
Strike Team turned heel and fled for
their lives although none of them got
very far Able's Rockets engulf the area
around them in a volley of explosions
leaving not a single thing standing he
had just effortlessly built an air
strike from virtually thin air and
thrown it at the foundation's last
remaining MTF agents and he wasn't done
there with his new found powers ael's
Campaign Of Destruction swept the entire
world in a last Act of desperation the
SCP Foundation offered freedom to any
anomaly that permanently took down SCP
076-2 they all flooded out of
containment to take their shot the
plague doctor the shy guy the Spectre
but they barely slowed AEL down his new
constructs were devastating weapons
taking the form of not just blade es but
projectiles of every size and shape all
of them lethal before long Abel had Lain
waste to the entire Foundation but still
he wanted more SCP 914 hadn't just
improved Abel's existing anomalous
powers and granted him the ability to
fly at supersonic speeds in doing so it
had Amplified his range too he loathed
the human race and sought to absolutely
decimate every single living thing no
one could best him in combat now and in
in his mind Twisted by anger not one of
them was worthy of his respect he tore
planes apart with his bare hands smashed
tanks to pieces and leveled entire
cities with his unlimited weapons it
took a few years maybe a decade at the
most but by the end of it Abel sat at
top a pile of billions upon billions of
bones with his refined abilities he had
done something Unthinkable committed
omnicide he had killed everyone in the
world world of course this was indeed
another world one different to ours
luckily here our version of able is
still locked up underwater but somewhere
out there there is an AEL who is
watching the sun rising over an entirely
dead World his world MTF agents scramble
through the crowd of bloodthirsty
hypnotized Festival goers up on the
stage a pair of living statues hold down
a screaming man as they produce medieval
instruments ments of torture from an
antique case maybe this time the agents
can stop it maybe they can prevent all
the horror and bloodshed but one thing
stands in their way a man-sized
cartoonish dove costume flying down
towards them wielding a large wooden
Mallet that would only bring death and
destruction needless to say even by
Foundation standards this one is going
to be weird when you found yourself
sought out by the SCP foundation's
recruitment division and offered a role
in the research department they made
sure to inform you of the risks after
all a workplace injury in this line of
work might be far more serious than
slipping on a wet floor or developing
carpal tunnel from typing all day
working within the ranks of the
foundation you could be the unfortunate
victim of any number of dangerous
anomalies whether it's scp096 appearing
behind you after you accidentally caught
a glimpse of it as a single Pixel in a
photo or if you were in the wrong place
at the wrong time whenever SCP 682 next
broke out then chances are you'd be
receiving an early redundancy and a
closed casket service if there's even
enough of you left to bury it is the one
thing you never want to happen the
scenario you're constantly warned about
from the moment you join the foundation
a Containment Breach anything can be the
cause of an anomaly Breaking Free of
containment and spreading Untold chaos
in the process whether it's the result
of a particularly kantankerous SCP that
doesn't take kindly to being locked up
an act of earnest human error with
disastrous consequences or even
International sabotage enacted by a
group of interests trying to seize
anomalies for their own purposes there
is no telling when or where a
Containment Breach might occur or is
there despite all the resources at their
disposal specialized facilities spanning
the globe advanced technology and a
nearly inexhaustible supply of personnel
to contain scps the foundation still
manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment
breaches but surely if they're so well
equipped such breaches should be almost
impossible right well yes so what causes
them what if every Containment Breach
all the loss of life the further spread
of anomalies and the destruction of
foundation property incurred was all
caused by an SCP not a living entity
mind you or some kind of latent
anomalous phenomenon that triggers
containment breaches without warning the
prevailing Theory surrounding this
phenomenon is even itself considered to
be an SCP within its own right referred
to as SCP 001 of course as many of those
well versed in the history and practices
of the SCP Foundation will already know
SCP 001 is a designation shared by a
number of anomalies some are believed to
actually exist While others are
speculated to just be falsified covers
created to mask the real SCP 001 from
beings such as the gate guardian and the
Scarlet King to the existence of God's
blind spot and even the foundation
itself each of these SCP 001's are
nicknamed after the foundation
researcher who proposed them for the
designation and often considered to be
some of the first if not the very first
anomalies ever encountered or at least
documented in that regard this SCP 001
plagues propos
could well be one of the very first
latent anomalies to exist explaining why
so many scps were uncontained prior to
the foundation being established and why
even now with all their resources
containment breaches are still a
worryingly frequent occurrence there are
multiple anomalies that appear to have
been directly affected by SCP 001 at
least according to the research of one
of the foundation's directors director
leg while he might be drawing
conclusions and seeing patterns where
there aren't any to speak of leg reasons
that the circumstances of these specific
recorded containment breaches seem to
indicate that scp1 was at fault the
first of these incidences director L
focuses on in his research is also the
one we'll be focusing on for the
remainder of this video it is designated
as SCP
scp-1 previously went under the
designation of SCP
5770 it is an annual anomalous event
that occurred in the P Deora in Florence
Italy the event consists of an
unscheduled Festival that goes on for a
period of 10 days where in anyone
present within a 10 km range of the
affected area suffers a mind altering
effect that compels them to attend the
festival however SCP 0011 is not a
well-documented long-running festival of
great cultural significance to the
people of Florence neither is it an
event that is widely advertised yet
those who have experienced erience the
psychic draw of this anomalous Festival
are driven to attendance during the
course of SCP
0011 two anomalous entities that resembl
the statues created by Michelangelo
during the Renaissance will host a show
where they take to the stage to judge
people they deemed to be Sinners this
pair of statue creatures will call upon
the audience and bring those they've
designated Sinners up onto the stage
with them and will then enact makeshift
grueling punishments these have been
noted to resemble the acts depicted in
Don alig's Inferno so if you ever need
any further proof of how hellish these
punishments are we recommend asking an
Art Expert the moment that SCP 00 1-1
ceases and the festival comes to a close
any and all in attendance are subject to
yet another form of anomalous mental
alteration and will proceed to instantly
forget the event any of the horrific
tortures performed on stage becomes
unknown to those that directly witnessed
it leaving them unaware of anything that
occurred only moments prior so given the
foundation's extensive knowledge of this
Festival its gruesome proceedings and
the effects it has on those in
attendance you might be forgiven for
expecting them to have a fairly
well-established method of keeping the
event contained presumably setting up a
cordin to keep attendance out of the
area administering amnestics to any that
might have been affected by SCP 001 d1's
anomalous mind altering but then you
remember SCP 001 the theory behind what
could be the cause of containment
breaches
as a result the foundation has still
been unable to establish containment of
the event formerly known as SCP 5770 and
director leg's research has tied this
issue with containment to SCP 001 hence
the festival's redesignation to SCP
01-1 following the initial discovery of
an anomalous annual occurrence in the
City of Florence in
1985 the SCP foundation's head
researcher assigned to what was then
known as SCP 5770 was one Joseph Pasqua
former site director at site 322 Pasa
was according to the incidents recorded
on the foundation's own database somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous
statue creatures that performed the show
during occurrences of SCP
5770 it was thanks to the influence of
this entity that Joseph Pasqua deserted
his post at the foundation and went into
hiding the fact that the influence of
one of the performers of this Festival
was able to extend its influence to a
ior member of the foundation was not
only troubling but also constituted a
Containment Breach Pasad would later be
tracked down by Foundation agents
operating in and around Italy he was
discovered 30 years later after his
desertion in Vatican City as a member of
the palpo conclave a specially selected
group of Catholic Cardinals that are
charged with electing a new pope if the
former site director was still being
influenced by the statue creatures it is
highly likely that he spent the previous
three decades climbing the ranks of the
Catholic Church potentially to install a
new pope at the behest of the entities
responsible for conducting the torture
of the Florence Festival another
recorded incident of a Containment
Breach surrounding the event that seemed
to lend Credence to the existence of SCP
001 the anomalous cause of breaches
occurred the year following as CP 5770
Discovery in 1986 the foundation was
observing the proceedings of the
festival as part of their ongoing
investigation into its bizarre nature
onsite were agents of mobile task force
Zeta 66 better known under their unit's
code name of the Guardian Angels during
the festival MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously
unknown entity associated with the
anomalous event the foundation was
already aware of the pair of seemingly
living Michelangelo sculptures
designating them as SCP
57701 and SCP
57702 respectively this third entity
despite being given the designation of
SCP
57703 had its own preferred
identification for itself the being
referred to itself as God's strongest
Soldier and resembled a mascot costume
of a dove approximately 2 m tall this
creature's body was entirely Hollow
there was nothing within the costume the
costume was its body the responding
agent of MTF Zeta 66 codenamed Zeta
turquoise was the first to confront
God's strongest Soldier and was greeted
with quite the opener twily de twily da
God's strongest Soldier is my name
getting rid of sin is my game confused
at the creatur's demeanor and presence
Zeta turquoise called in a report to
command stating that a large Birdman was
harassing random attendants of the
festival when turquoise moved in to
confront SCP
57703 the creature repeated its
assertion that it was God's strongest
Soldier and that its aim was to get
people into heaven the agent requested
that God's strongest Soldier get out of
his way he had a job to do but the
bizarre Birdman responded with more
Whimsical nonsense burger sandwich fruit
and Fries you just told a big fat lie
God's strongest Soldier
proclaimed upon Zeta turquoise' attempt
to push past the creature SCP 57703
produced an oversized wooden Mallet
seemingly from out of thin air it then
wound its arms back and immediately
viciously struck the MTF agent a low
orbit Foundation satellite report
reported not long after that an object
had been detected exiting the Earth's
stratosphere analysis confirmed that it
was indeed Zeta turquoise yes he was
literally yeed into Earth's orbit by a
cartoonishly large wooden Mallet as for
the entity known as God's strongest
Soldier the birdlike creature then
proceeded to attack the other members of
mobile task force Zeta 66 in a similar
fashion making sure they got to heaven
in every sense of the phrase with
multiple recorded instances of
containment breaches occurring in
relation to the festival in Florence and
happening so frequently more and more
evidence of director leg's theory about
SCP 001 was being validated in 1988 the
foundation attempted a different more
pacifistic approach to containing the
annual Celebration by attempting to
cordin off the entrance to the area of
Florence where those compelled to attend
the festival usually congregated there
was additionally a cover story issued to
the public stating that this was done as
a quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially
dangerous infection for a time this
seemed to be working the streets were
quiet local residents seemed to be going
about their business and paying little
mind to the foundation operatives in the
area that is until the mind altering
effects of SCP 0011 took hold a mass of
people estimated to be over 100,000
florentines charged towards the coff
area this mass of people swept through
like a tidal wave breaking through a dam
causing Foundation Personnel to be
trampled alive those that survived the
initial Rush were attacked by civilians
and what seemed to be a coordinated
effort to reach the Gatherings area for
the festival all Foundation agents in
the area were terminated in short order
mercilessly slaughtered and then
cannibalized before anything that
remained of their bodies was dumped into
the Arno River nearby as well as being
evidence of the sheer mental alteration
the statue creatures and the festival
itself were capable of for director leg
this seemed to indicate something
further if an anomaly SCP 001 was truly
responsible for all containment breaches
allowing them to occur in spite of the
measures taken to prevent such things
happening then the phenomenon seemed to
be occurring specifically to prevent the
foundation from achieving containment of
certain scps legs theory developed with
every passing breach that involved SCP
00 1-1 in theory the festival should be
an average Tuesday for foundation staff
a relative walk in the park in order to
contain it if not outright stop it from
happening at all yet despite all their
resources Manpower and expertise and all
things anomalous the foundation had been
thwarted at every turn despite how
illogical such occurrences seemed
containment breaches were still
occurring at an alarming rate and
perhaps none more so than in relation to
SCP 001 the following year 1989 brought
with it the most inexplicable breach yet
and further proof for director leg's
theory about SCP 001 well the previous
breaches were undoubtedly anomalous in
nature each always carrying with the
possibility that somehow despite the low
odds the foundation missed something
some human error or previously
undiscovered information about the
festival could have led to pasqua's
alteration or the arrival of God's
strongest Soldier but this time it was
undeniably that a force beyond the scope
of the foundation's understanding was
altering reality to prevent them from
containing the festival in Florence an
invisible barrier manifested at every
entry point to the main area of the
anomalous event whenever a member of
foundation Personnel tried to get in on
foot those that attempted to access the
festival area via repelling out of
helicopters instantly caught a blaze and
burned to death the moment they touched
down on the ground any helicopter
transports also crashed on their return
journey to site 322 and God's strongest
Soldier was seen trampling on the
wreckage before flapping its arms and
flying away it was following this
incident that leg was promoted to POS
position of site director for site 322
as a replacement for Joseph Pasqua who
was still missing at this time the newly
appointed director was yet to devise his
theory that there existed an anomalous
cause for all containment breaches
however during his introductory briefing
he was presented with the file regarding
SCP 5770 and the various examples of it
not only being uncontainable but being
very good at not being contained
director Lake asked if some of the more
standard methods had been attempted at
this point the foundation had tried
aerial bombardments at the festival
Scranton reality anchors to counteract
whatever anomalous force was preventing
containment even using a CP 682 to clear
the area it had all failed figuring out
why was now director leg's job all the
information of previously failed
attempts to contain the festival LED leg
to the conclusion that SCP 001 must
exist an unseen phenomenon the missing
piece of the puzzle the elements
specifically interfering with the
foundation's efforts he presented his
proposal to the overseer Council who
were skeptical to say the least they
posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the
latter's outwardly cartoonish nature
portrayed but this is exactly what to
director leg indicated SCP 001 was
responsible he explained that all in
attendance at SCP 577 Festival took the
event seriously but the appearance of
God's strongest Soldier was an
abnormality whose demeanor and tone were
drastically different from the rest of
the rather Cutthroat proceedings
director leg explained that the sheer
absurdity of this creature seemed to be
the result of SCP 001 interfering with
their operations after all if some other
cause was to blame like an unknown cult
attacking Foundation Personnel when they
attempted to contain the festival then
there would be evidence of that and leg
would have no reason to suspect that
God's strongest Soldier was anything
more than just a tonally dissonant part
of the festival of course director leg
couldn't prove the existence of SCP 001
based on the presence of one cartoonish
bird mascot at a festival but before
long more and more breaches would start
occurring that seemed to further prove
that leg was on to something there was
something else at work causing
containment breaches that put the
entirety of the foundation in Jeopardy
the helicopter lurched and rumbled as it
made its descent through the veran insk
mountain range conditions were harsh
with Fierce winds ripping Through The
Valleys at any point a blizzard
threatened to strike just about managing
to touchdown mobile task force Lambda 9
was glad to be out of the vehicle even
if it meant stepping into kneee snow
there were eight operatives in total
early reconnaissance suggested that they
were the only people present within a 5
km radius at least that's certainly what
they hoped L9 operatives 1 through six
all made their way up through the
Mountain Pass leaving seven and eight
guarding the chopper this was a simple
reconnaissance mission they would need
to search the bunker for any signs of
Life gather Intel and get out hopefully
before the snowstorm hit all eight of
them were kitted out with the
foundation's kter grade Cutting Edge
anti- cionic plating the operatives had
all been chosen carefully with L 9-1 the
leader being an experienced Soldier
serving 11 years in the unit he had
capable psionic powers himself and
approached L 9-2 who showed some of the
same gifts all of a sudden as the group
rounded the final pass and caught sight
of the facility both one and two
experienced severe migraines battered by
the Russian wind they had no choice but
to get to the bunker as fast as possible
it looked relatively unassuming a small
concrete slab sitting amongst the
mountains the six of them gathered
around on either side of the doors as
number three forced his way inside
following standard breaching Maneuvers
the rest of the team followed suit
charging in through the open doorway and
immediately tipping forward into an
abyss they all landed hard side by side
on the slope some of them rolling down
clattering against each other and
eventually skidding to a stop very
gingerly the groups started to get back
to their feet and catch their breath as
the wind had been knocked out out of all
of them they weren't in a research
facility at all the Soviet concrete
walls they' been expecting the old Compu
computers and the lab equipment were all
missing instead they were standing in a
void infinite and white with no seeming
end in any direction beneath their feet
and curling up above them was an
enormous double helix a rainbow of
colors weaving in and out of one another
it was like they had found themselves
standing on an enormous strand of DNA
floating all around them were glowing
orbs of light none of them could tell
how near or far these orbs were they
could have been close enough to reach
out and touch or they could have been on
the other side of the universe and
slowly one by one they noticed the
doorway that they had come in through it
was perpendicular to the double helix
and floating about 3 m above their heads
through it they could see the snowy
Russian Mountains their only chance of
Escape four murmured something about
needing to leave one argued back at him
they had no idea whether that door was
real or an illusion they had no idea if
they would even be able to pass through
it besides it was 3 m above their heads
and floating out over the void it was
risky but for didn't care much about
receiving permission taking a few steps
back further down the double helix to
get a good runup he braced himself and
sprinted as fast as he could before
jumping and reaching for the open
doorway it was as if gravity was
suddenly much stronger as soon as he
stepped off the double helix four was
wrenched downwards tumbling and spinning
accelerating faster and faster he let
out a petrified scream that sent the
other operatives cowering there was no
bottom at least not as far as they could
see or hear for's body just got smaller
and smaller and his screams quieter and
quieter for several minutes until the
agents couldn't hear him anymore and yet
inside the heads of one and two the
psionic members of the group that
screaming sound only seemed to grow
louder December 25th
1962 a man walked briskly through
through the West Berlin train station he
shaved his head the night before and
trimmed his beard down to a thick
mustache dark sunglasses covered his
eyes and a fedora was stepped forward he
hoped that his limp was convincing as he
shuffled his way through the crowds one
advantage of wearing dark sunglasses in
the middle of winter was that he could
constantly scan the faces of those
around him looking for anybody who
looked Russian his train had been
delayed an hour outside of Berlin the
train had ground to a Hal German police
officers had walked the length of the
carriages checking everyone's tickets
and passports it felt like an eternity
the man was too old by this point to
attempt to run away besides running
through rural Germany in the snow didn't
sound like the best plan so he stuck to
his cover story and hoped against hope
that the fake passport he bought would
be convincing enough fortunately for him
the officer checked it he looked to be
about 18 years old the man doubted that
the boy would know a Russian passport if
it was signed by Nikita crev himself but
shuffling through the station his
feeling of unease grew Russian deserters
had been poisoned all around him for the
prior 15 years a number of his own
colleagues had mysteriously gone missing
after feeling disenfranchised by the
Soviet agenda it was such a high-profile
Target that there was no way the KGB
wasn't actively hunting him down at that
very moment he clutched the briefcase
tightly and made his way out of the
station his plan had been to call a taxi
but now the prospect of being alone in
an anonymous vehicle with only one other
person terrified him his best protection
would be to stay out in the open as much
as possible he would walk to the British
Embassy or rather he'd pretend to limp
there Lambda 9 operatives number seven
and 8 stood by the helicopter shivering
their team had been missing for hours
now and they could see the blizzard
slowly covering the mountain range like
a blank blanket before long it would
reach them if their helicopter got
buried by anything more than a couple of
inches all hopes of evacuating back to
base would be dashed as soon as their
team had gone through the doors into the
facility all radio contact with them had
been cut off the foundation had
suspected that the bunker would be
heavily insulated but if that were the
case surely one of them would have
stepped outside to resume radio contact
and report what they had found so far
then all of a sudden seven went limp he
remained standing but his head and
shoulders slumped forward as if he'd
fallen asleep perhaps he had been
standing out here for too long Aid was
about to Rouse him when suddenly seven
started talking hello eight can you hear
me it's one are you there the
conversation moved quickly somehow one
had been able to reach out to Seven's
mind and temporarily take control in
order to use him as a mouthpiece to
communicate with the foundation over the
radio this kind of contact would
normally have been well beyond what one
would have been capable able of but he
explained that as soon as they had
entered the facility both he and two had
felt their powers growing immeasurably
the foundation asked for a situation
report and one updated them about what
had happened to four trying to escape
through the door he jumped and fell
through the abyss but what was more
sickening was that they had seen for
again all of a sudden they had started
to hear his screams physically not
psionically and he had fallen past them
just off to their right almost within
touching them distance having decided
that it was too risky to attempt an
escape as four had done the group of
them made the decision to travel further
down into the facility descending along
the Helix for the next 3 hours s is
unresponsive he stands there limp in the
snow hunched forward and not speaking
despite eight and the foundation's best
attempts to wake him command we found
something the Helix branches off a bit
there's a doorway there I can see inside
it looks like a lab of some kind we can
walk to it hopefully it's a way out
command sent authorization for them to
proceed and so they did one reported
that it appeared that they were back in
the real world the abstract shapes and
colors the infinite void was gone they
were in a Soviet research lab there was
medical equipment everywhere syringes
and jars full of well maybe it's best
not to know what was in them as Lambda 9
walked through the facility checking
every corner before rounding out they
felt a profound sense of unease surely
enough that feeling was warranted
rounding the corner one found some human
remains the man appeared to have been a
researcher at one point his brains were
now stretched out and stuck to the walls
like Silly Putty what the hell happened
here safely on British soil the man who
had defected from the Soviet Union sat
in the interview room chewing his bottom
lip he had spent so much time focusing
on how he would escape with his life
that he hadn't spared much thought for
what he would say once he was on the
other side they had codenamed him Iceman
but he didn't feel particularly cold at
that moment he felt nervous but he did
his best to hide it I was a project
manager in the psychotronics division of
the main intelligence directorate I
oversaw project Redline which was
commissioned by Joseph Stalin following
the second world war and before he knew
what he was doing he told his
interviewer everything over 20 million
Soviets had died during the second world
war their death told Eclipse that of any
other country Iceman had witnessed it
all so when Stalin had come to him with
the task of creating an ultra powerful
psychic weapon something that could
convert the entire world population to
adopt Marxism leninism the man had his
reservations activating a device like
that could trigger a war even deadlier
than either of the two already
experienced that Century he was part of
Gru division P the Russian arm of Highly
classified experimental research
conferring with his team they devised a
plan they would argue they needed
absolute secrecy to carry out their work
even away from the watching eyes of the
KGB rather than create a weapon they
would create a tool for peace instead of
promoting the values of Communism they
would create a psychic tool to dampen
Humanity's inclination towards violence
and aggression their method would be
brutal but un necessary evil in short
their theory was the psychic mind is
often Limited by the human body a young
child could have incredible psychic
potential but their physical limitations
would hold them back from exercising it
therefore they needed to separate mind
from body and they had just the trick
for that traumatic disassociation they
would take a young gifted psychic and
tear out their mind in order to transfer
that mind into the body of a
controllable Avatar Iceman explained
that none of them could have expected
how much fate would look favorably on
them just 2 years years prior the KGB
had captured and brought in a set of
triplets for them the triplets were
incredibly rare conjoined at both the
head and the Torso with three arms and
six legs it was a miracle they were
still alive so Iceman and his team set
to work immediately they dosed the
triplets up with as many mind-altering
chemicals as they could physically
endure before electrocuting them for
prolonged periods whilst reading antiv
violent manifestos to them it worked the
triplets mind Associated and the Soviets
were able to capture it Iceman was not
forthcoming about what they did with the
mind or where they transferred it all he
explained was that it worked they took
the weapon to the norog gulag 50,000 of
the most vicious criminals known to men
Luthers murderers Psychopaths dropped
their makeshift knives and refused to
move an inch even as we threw the gates
of the camp wide open we did that the
final test was on Nikita crev and John F
Kennedy from thousands of kilometers
away they activated project Redline and
influenced the two world leaders at the
height of the Cuban Missile Crisis war
was averted but crev was Furious he
removed the entire team killing a number
of them and began to weaponize project
Redline if they could fire it at an
advancing Army they'd never lose a
single soldier ever again to do this it
needed to be stronger they were to
implant the Consciousness into another
subject torture them further and
disassociate again amplifying the Psy
abilities mobile task force Lambda 9
were stuck in the facility the blizzard
had been so strong that seven and 8 had
to return to base the previous night and
come back having spent a night lost in
wandering through the Helix descending
deeper and deeper the team had noticed
that the world around them was getting
darker periodically they could hear
Force screaming and falling past them
once again before dropping out of sight
again beneath them they had tried to
catch him to pull him back but he was
always just Out Of Reach desperate to be
saved seven and 8 returned and their
psychic puppet radio contact was resumed
with command the team found another door
searching through it they were horrified
to find their own corpses floating in
the air in front of them dressed up in
lab coats just like the scientists from
the levels above them their brains were
stretching out and lying together in
some kind of web yet further down the
Helix they found another door one and
three decided to go inside leaving the
rest of the team standing on the Helix
ready to catch four if he fell past
again
this time two was in contact with
command through his psychic link to the
men by the chopper he soon reported
hearing four screams getting closer and
closer the group stood around ready to
catch him there he is I can see him he's
definitely Falling Towards us yeah I see
it too command there's something up with
for it looks like he's spread eagled his
arms are stretched out he's he's
screaming it's not getting louder it's
getting flatter there would be no
further contact with two five and six by
the time 1 and three returned from Scout
in out the room they were alone one
couldn't even sense the presence of any
of their squadmates anymore they had no
option but to continue to descend the
Helix into the darkness the smell of
burning flesh filled their noses The
Echoes of death were all around them
voices cried out in pain and fear and
then new voices speaking in Russian cut
over the top stop it give in don't
resist resisting is bad you will be
punished if you resist East begin
electrical discharge 500 volts 3 amps
increase voltage every minute the
operatives had no choice but to listen
to the memory of the triplets being
tortured not just the sounds but the
emotions that flood them those weren't
someone else's memories anymore they
were becoming their own and just as they
saw into the mind of the triplets the
triplets saw them in return command it's
trying to open me up like it did
everyone else but I can see into it it's
learning from us it knows all about me
the squad the foundation they're almost
on me it's it's the conjunction the
scientists the monsters that made this
thing the ones it knew before it died
was that they wanted it to conjunct it
wants to make us part of it don't come
back here it wants to make the whole
world part of it and at that moment the
entirety of mobile task force Lambda 9
dropped dead in that same moment a
multicolored sphere of energy 5 km wide
appeared over the facility dwarfing the
mountains around it designated SCP 2664
daa for years the foundation dropped
psionically dampening materials and
psionically stumped d-class Personnel
into the sphere in hopes of slowing its
growth no other containment measures
could be acted upon that was until 1300
hours on the 25th of December 2000
Christmas Day SCP 2664 daa suddenly
fluctuated releasing an enormous amount
of psionic energy that resulted in the
brain death of all humans within a 200
km radius the following day at 1700
hours a global cult Coalition satellite
launched a spherical payload right into
the heart of SCP 2664 daa for 13 minutes
tremendous amounts of radiation were
detected emanating from inside the
sphere before just as suddenly as it had
appeared SCP 2664 daa disappeared
entirely leaving just the payload in its
place before the foundation was able to
recover the payload it launched into the
atmosphere and was lost subsequent
reconnaissance operations to the site
have confirmed no abnormal radioactive
or psionic readings to all intents and
purposes SCP 2664 appears to be gone as
such the file has been marked as
neutralized long may it stay that way
now check out SCP 407 Unit 731 and SCP
1862 end all wars